me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
all right and we are sort of kind of
live
what's going on around talk to me how
are we doing out there
hustling motivate my guy he called
fusion what's up razor x gun damn
evil fan 76 pecan fusion
death mobile what's going on
getting ready for the show got a lot of
snow in new york new jersey
connecticut tri-state we have woke up to
another five to seven inches of snow
so i'm not happy making sure i see you
got the eyeballs and popcorn i see you
brother
and i'm saying squirrely what up
nobody's giving you a free copy of mass
effect trilogy squirrely so stop that's
not happening go play the game
nah lies what's up oh man
yeah a lot of snow y'all so i'm running
a little a little tired
you might give away a mass effect
trilogy to the patreon
so you might get lucky and win one of
them you already said that's what you
might do
no vag what's up brother p what's up
good people
so yeah man we're just waiting for the
laser coin you know what i'm saying west
coast or whatever king will be rolling
in soon so i've already spoke to
so we should be fully stacked just beat
the laser core and give me the
acknowledgement
but um yeah i'm going to see y'all in a
bit close up
shout out gameplay
yeah it's it's crazy man this this is
the part of the east coast i can't stand
all the deal shovel in the snow what's
crazy is like the past couple years we
ain't really got that
but this year this is like an old winter
like it's old school yeah there's old
school
new nor'easters el domingo am i
that's what's up all right so i'm gonna
see y'all in a bit
king and everybody should be rolling up
and going on the corn and solve
and see out of it
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lord's
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game
just be original y'all so dramatical i
know it's random but i'm addicted to
flipping the sample and making
[Music]
them to be your dog thing very loyal but
i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here to
boy you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed
but that's all a part of me being
accountable and they say i'm better than
money because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beating
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game
just be original y'all so dramatical i
know it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start
regardless back with messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing that
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they wanna compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game
just be original y'all so dramatical i
know it's random but i'm addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical
and yeah i'll be eating these rappers
but that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game
just be original y'all so dramatical i
know it's random but i'm addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on aim check my
[Music]
thing very loyal but i ain't gonna hold
you i ain't here to boy you you ain't
gotta say it i'm embarrassed for you i
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they're really
mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat
beating they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them reigns you just a target when i'm
in the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal um
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled feeling to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tiller uber
cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lord's
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
[Music]
i
videos
[Music]
loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't
here to boil you you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i've always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you
hear you man welcome to the show if you
would not mind go ahead and uh find
yourself a spot get comfortable grab a
snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i am addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back
with messaging people check my vocals
all on twitter but i'm anti-social love
my city but i'm still by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i'll be eating these rappers
but that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so
i know it's random but i'm addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to
[Music]
um
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started
i am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i am addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable this is
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back
with messaging people on aim check my
vocals
[Music]
but
[Music]
imma just chill and watch them any
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for attic
if i can imagine this cooler give you
some advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that option you gonna be single player
like siren you're gonna get tossed in
the bushes by king david
royalty not a pretender detrimental to
an elemental what's an avatar to a knee
bender i gotta be me though
i know it's my destiny worked a cognito
who cares if you fly if you steal a
moquitos
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news
even if you really was that jew king
david still be the king of the statues
since a juvenile i've been cursed with a
curse to be musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in the crucible was it
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
fortunate but whatever you want to do
then it's doable if you got work on a
sunday it's suitable cause you can
listen to this in your cubicle on the
lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen
[Music]
how to do that what is that about
and this is why
and we are live hear you hear ye
welcome to the iron lord podcast and the
lords of gaming.net episode number 195
and it's another glory sunday we're back
at the round table on the lord's day
i'm very excited about our special guest
and we've got mass effect
legendary edition microsoft acquiring
sega
and konami and stadium shutting down
studios to discuss
so we're gonna get right into it i want
to introduce the lord whose creative and
diverse mix of gaming content combined
with his trademark humor
always results in pure entertainment for
the gaming community
introducing the creating host of the
lasercorn youtube and lasercorn show
twitch
channels the lord of mods
and classic connect games and husband to
one of the coolest gaming families in
the realm
live from l.a and making his debut
into the realm of the lords mommy
lord lasercord how are we doing sir good
how are you thank you so much for having
me how's it going
doing good brother glad glad you're here
man like i said uh i'm glad we got
worked out the logistics man
so cool you need to take some of this
snow that we have with the east coast
over to you in
the west coast i would love to my son
loves snow and he hasn't gotten to see
any in a while thanks to the
the pandemic because we usually fly back
to ohio for the winter so oh
okay unfortunately uh not happening
not happy this time who the hell chases
snow
i'm so fed up with this snow
nope i was uh well in high school i was
a snowboard instructor
oh my god so yeah so i like the
you walk outside and they're playing in
the snow they're throwing snowballs
i'm i'm that grumpy dude like don't you
throw that sniper
exactly you get bad we will
at the round table or what you've been
playing man what games you've been
playing later
uh i'm playing a lot of magic the
gathering arena
right now i'm i'm also playing the new
spider-man
uh unfortunately i don't i don't have a
ps5 yet
uh so i'm playing it on ps4 but i'm
playing the miles morales spider-man
uh i'm not missing anything don't worry
about it
i mean yo definitely it i think
playstation did a great thing
because for they knew a lot of people
wasn't going to be able to get a
playstation 5.
so you know playstation you're not
missing anything because they don't have
retraction
leading the witness wow the game
literally has ray racing
[Laughter]
anyway you're a german of uh miles
morales sir
yeah yeah i'm having fun with it uh i
haven't beaten it yet uh
my son started playing it and then i
watched him and i'm like oh man i gotta
start playing because he plays on like
the friendly neighborhood difficulty
and then i kick it up a couple
difficulty levels and i i put it on
it's it's funny watching him play he uh
the first time he
the the rhino comes out of the cage in
the very beginning yeah he uh
he just like paused it and like handed
me
i don't know he's not your fight yeah
he's like i'm not built for this dad
he's six now he's six oh beautiful but
he just turned six so he's
he's a new six no he said he's new sex
it's awesome to have you here good stuff
uh let's start with the super chat real
quick before we get into the lords intro
uh
sure we have smitty smith with the five
dollar super chat
bontes is like the hawk moon with
opening shot cause you need that salute
lord of baptist i got that i got that
god rule i got that shout out to that in
the eyes of tomorrow
i ain't doing none of that
then we have ever born saga with two
dollar super chat yo whoever
whoever was spitting in the waiting room
is fire
shout out to dallas man of our 2xp
podcast levelonegaming.com salute them
brothers fame and the team
but yeah if you want them bars dallas
outdoors
and bars ever born again with the 5
super chat the only people that like
snow are the ones who don't have to
shovel
savagery i got children
i have indentured servants
spanish parents be like and and handle
that please
you're gonna shovel that damn stuff
that's right
anyway
and you already know we got the full
hospital gaming those original lords on
the realm here at the round table
with those five-minute time-sensitive
laser corners here intros
but brother from another brother the
difficult game conqueror lord of his own
world and the how
of the young wolf my man lord addict how
we doing sir
i don't even know why you say we have
five minutes because you know that king
gonna time me like you know you know two
minutes into my intro he gonna tie me so
so i'm gonna say i'm playing
we're gonna pass it to uh to sovereign
sorry time in
my name i'll be respecting the game i'm
gonna use addicts extra time yeah oh
my gosh you better use it because
somebody else
let me get them right quick with the
2000 chat it's snowing out here
nights like this yeah he loved that
looked elemental feel you already know
what it is and of course we have
the most technical gaming lord the solo
gamer who lives with a single player
selfish experience
and also the sastradamus the lord of
clarity and lord patriarch of the iron
bank
my man lord sophomore how are we doing
sir
it's snowing again why is it snowing
again
from the first one oh yeah this is your
first year with the car
i haven't dug out for listen i went i
went to check on the car right
we have 15 inches i had 15 inches of
snow on the top of the car
right so i'm like i i'm i'm pressed for
time i'm like let me just get the top
layer off and that took me an hour just
to do that yep
um and then beyond that
my two wonderful you know neighbors to
the left and the right of me decided
that it
was a good idea to leave mountains of
snow in front of my car
rather than do the neighborly thing and
you know shovel it to the sidewalk
so no so i looked at that and i was like
nah i'm good
i'm enjoying it i've been unshoveled
since the first uber baby
uber wow have you been getting inside
your car and turning
your car around yes yes oh okay at least
you should be doing it yeah this at
least you i mean
new car owners do weird new things and
yeah right now that will kill your
batteries
yeah so um yeah so that's that um the
only thing i've gotten to play this
week because it's been a crazy week is
uh i picked up hybroxia too
from the old game so um yeah money for
that
i did pay money for that that is cut
that is colin moriarty's uh
classic classic 2d shooter beautiful
game
uh kind of bullet hellish a lot of
different uh power-ups
it grows uh sideways and up and down too
so if you like our type if you like like
life force stuff like that beautiful
sounds nice
that's absolutely that's been it and of
course we have the incredible hulk of
this aka
the access gamer the prophet of
xbox king of the statues who demands
nothing less than that premium
experience it is the leader of the fraud
alert movement
beloved lord king how we doing sir i'm
doing incredible guys
yo check it out
let me see the dolph now now that was
that was last week's wild unboxing you
know what's funny when you unbox those
i thought it was one statue
you're just switching the sides off and
at the end
i see there's like eight statues off you
say i'm exaggerating but i was like no
oh
that wasn't the same statue so that day
actually it was eight that was my mega
unboxing day
mm-hmm um you know it was a big day but
yesterday
i got the holy spirit of that that hulk
buster
this this is what six thousand dollars
look like in your face
[Applause]
and it's absolutely totally everything i
wanted it to be
it's utterly amazing uh check out golf
castle x
where i'm live on fridays at 9 00 p.m
in my live unboxing see that what what
king's failing to tell you that big box
in the back
on the floor he got a statue of himself
made and that's where that is
xm studios king david
exam studio presents
[Laughter]
it's literally a statue of him like
biting an x-box
you know you just gave him an idea
i might get that commission i got to
have my um my xbox uh
uh show all along listen guys
thank you for showing up i do appreciate
everybody who came down show uh
showed up and was showing support smitty
smith is crazy that is my dude
what i've been playing this week i want
to get rid of get to this really quickly
um i finished the medium oh yes love the
game
um but the end to me
oh you know i really because
it's left in a manner that i didn't feel
you know
satiated me okay but then there was
something else because somebody told me
to stick around and watch that i heard
something about sticking around cut
scene like a post credit almost yeah so
i saw it and i was like man it gives it
hope
okay it might have some legs on it for
something else
but i wanted a definitive ending because
of the atrocities that was committed
inside the game i wanted a definitive
ending and that ending wasn't definitive
to me
it might be definitive if they do a
special edition to address it like
renault mass effects did
uh but i i hope they do and i can answer
that for you they're not doing that
well they already this is this is the
thing about blueberry that i i wish they
sort of
reigned back in is that they're like
they're already on to the next one
all right they've released five games in
in four years or four games in five
years something like that
the cadence is super quick and i wish
they would take a little more time with
each game and abolish them
i wish they each had yes they already
have kind of hinted at what the next one
is
i feel like medium would have drawn a
lot more people and if it was like a
little bit more of an eye candy game
just for sure yeah a little bit more
polished and you got a next generation
pop
because they got the story lines they
got the narrative they got the horror
genre online they needed yeah
the the the sheen to it yes because um
i'm i'm in game pass right now so i'm
playing cyber shadow
uh and i'm playing uh you know some some
rpgs and stuff like that i
i think i did the raid with you this
week right at it we did it three times
yeah
it was i don't remember that it's been
such a long week that's when we was
doing the supers
trying to get all the supers to get that
oh you talking about when you left i
spent two hours on one last boss
i do apologize i do apologize for
stranding
you because i try to train people up
at the last boss to make it less uh
you know uh hectic so i do call outs
yeah
all right so anyway but i got back to
control guys oh all right
and uh just like solving said i got to
give sovereignty's credit i got a better
name when you get that levitate power
the game opens up in a different way the
narrative starts
a little bit different you know when you
start talking to
the brother and stuff like that the game
starts to turn in a different way but
then
that's when the true eye candy of the
game starts to show up because there's
different things that does happen
and all i can do is sitting there saying
damn i really wish blueberry team had
a little bit more polish because control
looks like and a lot of it's probably to
do with
finances too yeah like i would say
someone like remedy games has way more
didn't sony um didn't sony uh back that
game
i don't know i don't know yeah because
the promotion they had the promotion for
the game for controlling
the show there was no it was fun
they did have they had like the
marketing yeah okay regardless of what
they had to market
anyway the game is starting to uh you
know breathe a little bit more life in
it so i'm almost finished with the game
but that's what i've been playing
and i think uh y'all guys was a little
bit on to something still
you know in certain areas for me but
yeah it's it's it's a lot pop
more polished and that's what i wanted
from uh and
and you're not and you're not playing
the uh the ultimate edition right
because uh
unfortunately i'm not giving them any
money yeah xbox owners aren't getting
that freebie their playstation
that's ultimately fine because i never
purchased the game to begin with
so you know if they can if they paid x
amount of dollars and playstation
decided oh here's something free
i paid zero dollars so
shout out the game pass you shout out to
the game
i don't need that extra experience i
didn't earn that i didn't know god bless
the shiny rocks that you got you got
shiny rocks god bless
i'm done anyway
uh we have gaming forte with the 5 super
chat
i give up i'll never get this rocket
launcher congratulations collido
you're more patient than me hope it
takes you to the moon we're gonna talk
about it
listen forte i got it
yeah that's another thirty yeah guys got
abandoned get my man forte's rocket
launcher
i don't gotta do
lord king iron man in or out of the
hulkbuster
nah he's gonna stay on the outside i'm
not gonna do that you know even
even my wife was telling me you know the
way he sticks
out too far is don't do that so he can
get bigger than he is there
okay so the whole face part right there
can come out you can take that little
guy
and put him in and he looks like you
know the hulk destroyed the um
the buster and he's coming out to attack
the hulk oh wow
that's insane wait is it wait is iron
man wearing
an iron man suit inside the hulk yes
just like the movie
in the movie remember he was flying
right yeah yeah and he um uh the suit on
top of him and he threw him in the suit
and then when the suit was off of him
you know he was able to climb out
unbelievable
we got one more we have the liz 22 with
the five dollar super chat
happy super bowl sunday lords getting
ready to watch my god tom brady win
number seven
and [ __ ] you're welcome all of my guy
you already know it's a little bro
salute
it's tom brady the goat i gotta give liz
some love in a minute so we all caught
up sir
yes sir all right of course we have a
gaming ninja himself
the shinobi aka cog of tomorrow
who got the rocket launcher from the d
stone quick raid
why couldn't we in a couple more weeks
of being able to tease
i was getting tired of y'all man wait
wait wait last week
we was in our bag
y'all was i was annoyed oh yeah salute
man oh
man it was a shout out to the liz who's
up in there he was part of the team that
helped me push me over the finish line
because i saw that in the chat that
y'all was gonna do a raid and i was 45
minutes late
one more and i was like i'm here i saw
your message late i'm like oh
man this is the only time that i leave
my my my notifications on and you'll see
me online and all you have to do is say
just come on king
i i don't even i don't even see you
that's all it be that's okay he didn't
even look for me
i put the message in i put the message
in the chat yo
9 p.m eastern right so no one responds
nobody be looking at that destiny
challenge
i'm happy you got it though i appreciate
it man yeah so it was very fun to get
that shout out
shout out to tj teddy the ladies we
going to get them this shout out to
ebantus who was in here earlier last
word was up with the bearded luke
amazing show oh man so much fun his
story about
how he hated destiny that they ended up
loving destiny absolutely amazing
does he hate taylor yeah he's not a halo
guy which is weird so anyway
when he said that i thought you were
going to go ballistic time
last thing um yeah we played uh gears
tactics still i'm on my second play i'm
at the very end
yakuza like a dragon movement medium i'm
gonna do it slow and uh hit man three
but let's get the super chats and then
we gotta do that uh that uh special
announcement that we have to do
so so we have the living flame with the
five dollar super chat hear
ye hear ye next gen on playstation
finally started with destruction
67 meta and you gotta pay for more story
ps stealing this j
oh my god man
you gotta let that rock
then we got gaming times patrick with
the five dollar super chat been waiting
for king all week after the mlb the show
feelings happy to be present for the iop
show listen man
there's nothing prettier than to look at
my dashboard on xbox
and to see the tile that says
and then you got people like me that
don't care anyway
racial gun damn quick super bowl
prediction i think i think chief's got
it but we're going to see
i know i know king's on the road to
brady but we'll see what happens but
anyway look
it's that time of the month y'all you
know what i'm saying you know what we do
here
you know what i'm saying lords of
gaming.net that log net we got to talk
about it man we've been very blessed to
have some amazing contributors to the
site
it's been really unreal i want to first
give a shout out to um someone
who's actually moving on and that's lord
undead he has been tremendous for us he
really helped pushed us across the goal
line with a lot of things
and now my boy you know he's he's moving
up the ladder
he's got he's got he's getting his
career his dream of being in the
industry has started so salute
to lord undead he's going to be excuse
me he's going to be working for android
central
so salute to those guys he was an
absolute beast it's still love on here
you know what i mean so i want to shout
him out and uh
pursue his dream so salute to lord
undead you know what i'm saying that's
amazing
but um yeah just happy that long that
was able to help put him in position
because he's super talented and uh yeah
man as far as the uh
other reason why we're here and the
random person has entered the chat
so yeah i want to you know we got to
salute the describe of the month and uh
this is a person who goes above and
beyond in the month and this was january
become a true
lord lose true scribe and this this lord
man he i call him the lord of
entertainment
you know i'm saying box office and pop
culture he's been killing it with the um
the wand division
he's been killing it with the godzilla
king kong i'm learning so much
through his entertainment pieces so
again also hitting up gaming news so
again
proudly present the winner of lognet
scribe of the month for january my man
lord david yurian what's going on
brother congratulations
thank you let me we need a quick speech
brother come on we need a speech
just basically do whatever i really want
to do and write whatever i feel and
it's great your background
your background sir yeah your background
makes me want to play ghost receiving
yeah
yes
[Music]
you cut in and out brother you couldn't
announce i guess because having me on
the podcast too
oh yeah brother anytime but again
congratulations keep up the good work
and hit up lawrence off because you will
get some log net swag of your choice or
i don't yes sir you know what i'm saying
we got to salute the wedding but keep up
the fantastic work brother
thank you all right brother have a good
one man enjoy it i appreciate it
no doubt solve super chats and then we
gotta we gotta move the show off
we have clutch man with the five dollar
two attack can't
can't watch live but who from xbox would
y'all think make a mission impossible
game
have a great show the initiative yeah
yeah
i don't know i wanted to be a rpg
i mean yeah and we have uh michael aka
bedsize finance with the five dollar
super chat
ah king xbox series s is sold out in
africa
and uk this is going to be too great a
time for xbox
good morning lord do stay blessed
why i have this song i'm going to get so
messy today
anyway are we all good yeah we're caught
up all right let's get into this thing
man so look
now that we've gotten all that i saw
we'll probably do next week next week
oh yeah apologies for that it's not sobs
in the bushes so yeah stop to the bushes
it's fine we finally threw him trade the
bushes today but it's go it's okay
but um look man now we got everything
straightened out the business and all
that
um i want to focus on lord lasercorn his
video game system history
his journey into content creation and of
course what led him to creating the
unique
and entertaining lasercorn youtube
channel so lord laserco let's start from
the very beginning what was some of the
first video game systems you had what
got you the gaming
i started on the nintendo uh nintendo
was the first system i ever had
uh so what which which nintendo yeah the
nintendo and
yes yes yeah yeah yeah i'll be here
i want to get the age right i was born
in 84. yeah
okay so uh yeah the original nes and
then uh
so i played like mario uh legend of
zelda all that stuff
and then um yeah and oh uh
what was like what was that football
game like bl uh something
blitz blitz or yeah called blitz which
one yeah not enough
wait for anything no no nes
i wanted to say yeah the old one where
they put the square around yeah
and when you were running back
touchdowns and stuff yes um so that's
kind of where i started and then
i was pretty much a nintendo kid so
nintendo into super nintendo
and then uh never had a sega but
i would play some sega games over my
buddy's house i really liked like uh
general chaos
yes and uh uh what was the other one
that we
i could only play on sega i don't
remember but there were a couple sayings
this
i really like then i switched to
playstation twisted metal stuff like
that
uh so i had playstation one
two and three yeah i've had all the
playstations
and uh and xbox okay so halo and stuff
like that
and uh now i have the series x and
that's kind of where i am console-wise
for a pc uh i got into uh
pc gaming because of warcraft 2.
okay yeah i uh i played that at a
buddy's house and then i
i uh begged my parents to to get a
computer that would actually play that
game so we could play those old
uh modem dial-up battles
yes and then you could uh you could
fight head-to-head over the line and
then if your mom picked up the phone oh
it was over it was a yeah yeah
it'd disconnect your whole game i was
winning
i had sappers at their town hall um so
uh and then like uh so the warcraft
series i
i loved uh warcraft 2 3 and then
starcraft starcraft 2.
um and then uh you know
i then i that was all before i started
making video game videos
then once we got into that playing a lot
of gta nice a lot of minecraft
uh and then just whatever was fun uh a
bunch of
random silly games uh has have any of
you guys ever played totally accurate
battlegrounds
i've never played that no anyone played
it so
i haven't
yes yes okay i do apologize i was
sharing it out on twitter
and oh that's okay so tell us about this
game what's this game about you
yes so it's uh it's like imagine
fortnite except
um with like wacky wavy inflatable arm
guys from
from that you see outside car dealership
and the weapons are all like super
ridiculous well they're not all super
ridiculous they have some like basic
weapons but then they also have
like the america gun with flags and
eagles on it and stuff
and like there's like a a weird like
laser thing that only shows up like once
every hundred rounds that'll like
blow up a huge section on the map and
stuff one time i joined
in and i don't know if they still do
this i i kind of played this a little
bit back in there heyday and but they're
uh
they're putting more effort into the
game now that they're done with whatever
they were working on
but uh at one point uh i joined into a
game and it was just all lightsabers
it's like everyone
has lifesavers so it's just people
running around slashing that so i love
that game
uh i i need to play it more um fortnite
i'm starting to get into i started to
get into after the marvel characters
oh y'all marketing for that was trump
yes
and i mean for a long time i didn't want
to play fortnite i'm like this game's
not for me but then i'm like oh you can
wait you could kill iron man okay
maybe i'll track for tonight that makes
the call that's easy
oh your man on the hill yeah
he's using the jet pack uh but then uh
and i play a lot of minecraft right now
because my son's really into minecraft
so uh i have to keep him alive and you
know
he uh he panics when creepers show up or
skeleton warriors and stuff
uh so trying to keep him alive in
minecraft it's so it's work it's a job
it's a job
yeah i just yeah what did the backyard
was that because you had this amazing
you know console history obviously
nintendo for the most part then you
transition to playstation
in between that were there any other
systems that may have come up maybe in
the 16-bit era
like the turbo graphics or maybe like um
you know some people had the um 3d like
these those off
beat says that weren't the main at the
time but like like they were kind of off
shoots
did anything to cross your path when are
you going to realize that
you guys are the minority oh my god
i didn't no i didn't play those what
were the explain to me about these
systems because i actually
i completely missed these yeah well
pretty much like so you started with
don't feel bad
most people missed it no it's it's funny
but like so pretty much idiots obviously
you had the the
it was the the genesis the sega masters
and all that stuff but generally around
the 16-bit era that's when nec's turbo
graphics 16 kind of came into play
then the 32-bit era there was kind of
like the 3do and other little
cd-based full-motion video systems and
then obviously 64-bit
we had uh what's going to n64 and all
that but also we had uh
the atari jack basically the system that
did not
win the generation is kind of what i'm
referencing
for example another one a big one that
we usually hear sometimes is the sega
dreamcast you know
a lot of people had the dreamcast or the
saturn you know what i'm saying doing a
32-bit area as well so i just wanted to
know if
you were aware of it or you just were
kind of in stuck in the nintendo
ecosystem
i was aware of the the dreamcast yes
but i didn't have any friends that
really had it and uh i think i
i think i probably looked at it when i
when i was trying to decide what council
because you know my parents are like you
can have one so i probably looked at it
when i was trying to decide what console
i wanted
and then i went with something else but
um playstation play yeah playstation
yeah i got to play twisted metal um but
uh
but so i've heard of that one i don't
think i've ever heard
of turbo graphics
that was uh any c that made turbo
graphics
um that was like really niche
like if you yeah you went inside a
electronic boutique uh one of those game
stores like that
uh it wasn't in the forefront you know
so trust me i understand why you didn't
hear that that's something you had to
ask the owner hey you got a terrible car
yeah exactly savage
savage anyway i'm very curious about it
now i want to look it up because it's
got a cool name you wouldn't think it
would have sold copies on the
name at all oh they spelled graphics
with an x oh yeah
oh yeah baby they had like they had
their little cards
in japan yeah it was the top uh console
in japan that was called the pc engine
right so it was outpacing nintendo and
sega
you know in japan and i mean until this
day you can still go out and find hue
cards
and stuff for it but in america they
thought that would translate here
right had terrible marketing yeah and
you know and it was a little uh
janky on how they was uh marketing into
the people like yeah
yeah but it really wasn't 16-bit
it was nec it was edc on the americans
really good
and you try a new emulator right now or
whatever we don't
recommend backup games but
[Laughter]
no try try what are those what are those
what are those what are those
oh my god that's cool like i said just
interesting to hear people's history and
stuff like that yeah
but all the playstation all that good up
what's up it's it's interesting that you
say emulator because it looks like half
the fun is actually getting a console
because this one looks like a spaceship
the shuttle
the pc engine shuttle yes oh you're
looking at this right
yeah i just i looked it up and then on
the same on the same wikipedia page
as uh it's got the shuttle it looks like
a spaceship or something with the
controller
what is it i want to get one of these
it's worth it because like i know you
like to play a lot of cooler or older
content sometimes but
what's cool about turbo they were the
first kind of to introduce the
the booklets thing called the
multi-attack where it's basically the
four-player
the five-player local co-op experience
so yeah yeah that was the first like
they had to perform the first because
you know nintendo
revolutionized it by putting it in the
console with the 64.
and you had all four ports but yeah
actually nec was the first they had an
adapter that went into the single port
that supported four other additional
controllers and it was kind of cool you
could
you could play four player games on the
super nintendo too we used to play
bomberman
bobberman yeah yeah yeah you could
multitap that yeah yeah they probably
did it first huh yeah that's cool
yeah so they inspired that i got a lot
of uh
i'll i have a lot of fond memories of
bomberman
and they see nintendo took that idea
from
uh pc engine from japan yeah right
because
we would play bomberman i think the
turbo tap came with bomberman it was an
nec game at first he was attacking
one of the two like dungeon explorer
bomberman but
when you got it see super nintendo
kicked it up a notch and nintendo kicked
it up a notch because you was able to
kick the bombs
and slide it over yeah yeah in the
corner
some fond memories yeah there was the
punch ability too i think you could
punch it over
if they were trapped in a little three
by three square yeah
you know how like mario parties ended
friendships yeah yeah i have mario party
ending friendships and bomberman
yeah mario party a bomberman and golden
yeah holy trinity of ending friendships
yes do you have that one friend that
picks a job
oh you can't pick one
dude your vendor says we saw the super
chat then we move on to
a couple questions for lord ladies and
gentlemen we got a picture of the g with
the two dollar super chat stop your
slander pc engine
ftw turbo fans in here
all right turbo graphics i see you then
we have aerodynamics the five dollar
super chat good day lords let's have a
super
sunday absolutely absolutely man
tremendous history a lot a lot of fun
stuff we'll we'll get back to
some more questions for you later but i
want to get into your your whole
personal journey as a concentrated like
oh
yeah what just kind of inspired you like
how did that start you know what i'm
saying as far as you getting into
content creation
so i uh i always liked uh editing i went
to school
uh ohio university and went on the video
organization okay
okay yeah and uh i
kind of fell into editing i started on
final cut and they swore to me up and
down that that was the
industry standard and when i got a job
somewhere i would eventually be
using final cut and then i moved out to
la and found that was not the case
over to premiere and uh i started in
actually video game journalism i
i started writing for a a outlet called
gamefront
wow and i actually attended my first
blizzcon and wrote stories for
gamefront uh there that was way back in
gosh what was it like 2010 or something
that was yeah that was like over a
decade ago um but that's where i did my
first i did my first blizzcon rook for
that
and then while i was writing for them uh
i had a bunch of other like side jobs
when i moved out to la i was a uh
like promotions guy for a radio station
one of those guys that
runs around throwing t-shirts at
everything i can see that yeah driving
around in the van yeah 98 7.
yeah we are like they're like the less
good k
rock but um if we're being honest
uh anyway shout out to that shout out to
those dudes
yeah i uh so i did that for a while
and then i i answered a craigslist ad
actually
that for uh people who could edit uh
but were also into video games and
wanted to do video game capture and
stuff
and i'm like oh yeah that sounds great
that's like my dream job i started
working for a channel called mahalo
they were very poorly run uh
and they got punished in the algorithm
for it he's like
he you started off like each editor had
to put out like three videos a week then
it's like
five videos a week then it's like three
videos a day and they got caught for
spamming yeah and so
obviously the quality of the videos went
down and they got caught for spamming
and they laid off
everyone pretty much the channel is
pretty much dead now it was very poorly
run but for a while there they were
doing very well and they could you know
they paid salaries
and then after that uh i hopped over to
clever games which is kind of doing the
same thing minus the terrible management
they got bought by a company that owned
smosh
which was at the time the the largest
channel on youtube
yeah and then uh smosh wanted to start
smosh games they're like well we already
have a channel that does gaming stuff
why don't we
uh combine you guys together and we'll
make a gaming channel that's how smosh
games started
that channel blew up became the quickest
channel to a million subscribers
and then uh post that uh i uh
i did that for a little while defy
actually the channel that owns
smosh and everything went under but
before that i had left the company
because i wanted to get my channel back
and there's a
whole content contract negotiation thing
that happened
behind that basically i couldn't get my
personal channel unless i left the
company so i did
and then afterwards after they
relaunched i came back for a little bit
and then
now i'm just kind of doing my own thing
but that's kind of where i'm at now nice
nice yeah what i what really what was
that decision
when they told you like okay you can't
get your content back unless you leave
it was weird it was not it was not a
good contract it didn't seem smart
because they were in contract
negotiations and we're like okay if you
want me to stay here one of the things
i want uh my my personal channel
youtube.com lasercorn
because they owned it because i was
stupid inside uh it didn't even exist
actually before them
but i'm like okay i'll make a channel
and you guys can own it and then you
guys give me a percentage
and then they like later negotiated out
the percentage somehow i was bad at
negotiations for a while
but i finally decided i'm like i'm gonna
stay on my ground i'm like look you guys
aren't really doing
you you weren't doing what you said you
were gonna do in terms of my channel
so i want it back and uh if you don't
you know
it was me and a couple other guys that
wanted their personal channels back too
right
we're out of here so they eventually
gave it back but with the weird
stipulation that
you couldn't fully own it until you left
the company so i left
and i like signed a contract that
allowed me to come back for like
freelance stuff
and then uh and then i did that for a
while and then the company went under
and all that stuff
so it was like a weird non-compete type
of yeah
yeah okay i get it i understand it now
because when you made it
it didn't exist when you started working
for the company but they
act like it was their ip because it was
you were working for the company at the
time right well the contract they sent
yeah and they uh
at the time they were like okay well you
make it and then
you know you'll get a cut of the revenue
and we're gonna like we're gonna
promote it like right they were
promoting it they're like hey go check
out this channel and they
they were taking most of the revenue and
stuff but then they uh
they they ace they stopped really
promoting it and they also
um they also stopped paying like they
negotiated out there the revenue cut for
me so it was just like
there was almost no point in so it was
an actual breach on their part so that's
why
it wasn't a breach no no they negotiated
it out so they were giving me a cut of
the revenue
up until a negotiation happened where
they said uh you know we're not going to
do this anymore
and i kind of caved i caved on that
point and then i came back and then i
was mad at myself for doing that so then
i came back next time
and i'm like oh you're cutting out the
revenue share then i want the channel
back
and i'm like i'm really gonna stand my
ground on this one and i got it
it was it was bad negotiating on me
followed by i think pretty good
negotiation but they don't
know you rebounded and made the
situation
shout out to iop one of my favorite
podcasts cog and david you guys rock uh
hello
chop liver oh yes yo rocks off
thanks thanks dealer also yes those are
bad negotiations sir
live and learn brother yeah yeah exactly
you know what it was
he won't pay that extra money to put
saul's name in there
[Laughter]
now i'm a salute to you because again
it's a learning experience right and
yeah
and the cool thing about it you know the
fact that you were able
to negotiate yourself right back at to
the table get your ownership back and
then now you've got this amazing channel
that it's yours
pretty cool story man and a lesson a
lesson for a lot of people you know i'm
saying to
to look at so salute it's easy to make
those decisions when you're having
you know a very big entity breathing
down your neck
yeah factual yeah yeah yeah man so one
thing i do i want to talk about is i
love about your channel is like
the diversity in the content like you
you got some cool stuff going on man
so one of the things i noticed is like
the mods the hilarious ones you do
you know those are cool and then like
what
the connect videos what's what made you
do for
the connect games dude the connect is
underrated let's go
connect avengers is great you get a
workout it's it's the only time i
you know get out of my seat and move
around like i have vr but i never want
to like
set up vr connect is out of the box grab
and go
yes and punching stuff i played a weird
octopus game where you're like an
octopus you have to grab stuff
down on a river i'm like this is great
it if you have kids
it gets your kids moving around couch
potatoes
yes uh and then yeah i really love that
avengers game
because like some of the if you watch
that video some of the
like the like fighting is actually
pretty cool yeah it's pretty good
they're like knocking people up in the
air thor is calling down lightning on
them i'm like this is great if you
i mean i'm not doing any of that stuff
i'm doing like this
screen on screen i'm a legend
so i really i don't know i think it's
fun and uh it has some underrated
capabilities to connect yeah
it has xbox record that yeah uh which
i've been using
yeah like like i said i've been playing
games with my son and i recorded
my his his and i our very first
fortnight duo's win
we won we had the connect set up and it
was easy i
i'm like oh that was our very first win
it's a moment in history and i'm like
yeah xbox record that and connect was
like yes sir
and i posted it to twitter so yeah i'm a
little disappointed the series x doesn't
have to
you know pick it live no no i'm with you
i still have my connection i looked at
this dead relic on top of the show
but i don't i so i saw that nonsense no
they wouldn't even know
they wouldn't even take my i got the
adapter no they would yeah
yeah they were like they were like no no
sir your stuff
trust me they didn't take my playstation
vr um
but my children still play dance dance
upstairs
oh with it and it's it is probably i
don't i don't care what anybody say i
thought the connect was revolutionary
when that whole campaign came out it's
spying on you it's
it's taking your information they're
watching you when you sleep
i'm like stop that stop that it's
actually really good is that what killed
it
yes yes because it was at a time when
people
didn't want to be uh seen or heard yeah
well you know they was worried about big
brother
you see their heard yeah but they but
they're busy saying alexa this is
what what's funny is people said that
but they're walking around with a phone
with a cabaret
but what it was it was i agree with you
king it was a it was like a
a bad combination of everything at one
time so people weren't ready for the
only digital age at that time yeah
funny on digital now they wasn't ready
for the camera you know
so microsoft were doing things that were
actually becoming mainstream now
but at the time i guess people just
wasn't ready for it and the messaging
wasn't the greatest you know what i love
you to connect about
the most and i'm glad you brought that
up that connect fitness
oh
and it was so much fun because it got
you up like you said get you up and get
you moving yeah
just sweat and do your push-ups and it
knew when you were cheating
yes connect to it knew when you were
cheating
it just wow it just proves that you know
you could have an amazing ideal an
amazing product
but if you if you show that in the wrong
way and have bad communication
you might as well throw that straight in
the garbage it's sad because i
when i watch more laser cars videos i
remember doing that stuff i remember
playing those games i remember playing
you know the ufc game and they had all
these little
goofy games but some of them were
actually really wonderful you know
connect sports connect adventures all
that kind of stuff
and it was it's a shame that it didn't
well 360
it blew yeah but it's a shame that the
success didn't continue
with the xbox one with the advanced
version of it
because they made you have it that's
what happened yeah it increased that
price by a hundred
no one wanted to pay that 100 per camera
they didn't want it
it was really that star wars game that
tanked it
it was like it was like the e.t of
connect but i remember
i remember when they made that fable
adventures game oh
i forgot about them i was like i want a
fable game not a fable adventurous game
facts yeah man look it's a tremendous
history man another question i got for a
little lazy court is um
another thing cool that you do is i got
the dungeon and dragons little podcast
going on
and then yeah that's a big thing right
now yeah and then you also do the card
games man just like
you know pick your poison fun stuff like
i love you like how did that kind of
take place
the board gaming stuff yeah uh and and
the cart stuff
well we uh we'd always been fans of like
uh magic the gathering and while we were
at smosh games we made some like fun
board game stuff
and uh we we had a show called board af
i think they still have it over there
and uh and so
um we were just in games we like and i
don't know if you can see in the
background but i have like hero quest
and like battle masters
i used to play all those really old hero
quest is like dnd
light and you get to kind of beat that's
my game okay here it
all the is guys which is great like
that's the that's the most fun role
right like trying to kill your friends
murdering your friends yeah i'm like i'm
like i want to do that stuff on my
channel that kind of like fun stuff so
like i just started doing it like i the
studio i converted from uh
it was a detached garage and i'm like i
have enough room where i could get
like people in here and get them and set
up a big table and play board games
i'm like i'm gonna do it and so we just
started doing it and before the pandemic
yeah we were we were playing a lot of
those games together and then uh and
then you know the pandemic hit and now
people don't come over so much
we tried we tried to do d and d uh
you know remotely yeah and like it's
been it's been a hassle i gotta i gotta
be honest with you
like getting all the different camera
feeds and editing it all together and
stuff
and the vibe is different because you're
like not in the same room together so
yeah you gotta read the room especially
if you dungeon master
yeah you're giving us scenarios i i
actually love this
i'm i'm a super nerd so please don't i'm
glad because it's it's a culture i'm not
familiar with i know king you got yeah
that
shout out to volacon if you guys i think
yeah i played it one time like when i
was like 14 i
never touched it since like i've always
wanted to jump back in that but
i've never had friends that played that
so it was always one of those things
where it's like
i guess i'm a victim of no friends
it's cool though like i just to see like
again it's something i've never done but
i i see
the investment and i see how much fun
people are having i think
probably the closest we came to it was
uh what was it what was the name what
the name of that book series oh
that to me was the evolution of the like
to choose your own adventure but that we
had the paper you had to write the hit
points and all that
so that's the closest i came to it and i
was addicted that was a solo experience
but
to see what i'm watching like laser coin
stuff and i'm like yo this is so
cool like they're really getting it
everyone has their role and then they're
killing each other and all that kind of
stuff so
let's salute are you the dungeon master
see now
you know you gotta watch no idea like i
have my dice
and stuff yeah man
you want to get in the game i uh so i
dungeon mastered my first game recently
that that's not even out yet
uh but i dm'd my first game recently it
was a blast
i hope to play dungeon master more like
i said in hero quest dm light yeah i was
argon all the time
right uh in a in an actual dnd game i've
only ever done it twice
and i i did it pretty much back to back
wow and uh
it was fun i i i did some stuff that
like wasn't wasn't real standard
rules fanatics out there they're going
to be mad at me oh you're breaking
protocol
oh yeah i was breaking protocol but yeah
it is really fun i'm glad to hear you
have the dice and stuff you got to get
everyone in a game you see well the
thing is like you said with the pandemic
and one i was closeted all right so you
just look at these dudes
right so i'm they're judging you right
now
right if i'm going to sit there and i'm
going to explain it to him like i have
to do a light and then i have to bring
it to
you know the heavy and as far as being a
dungeon master we had a really good
dungeon master
but i have lost contact with him it
takes
a lot to be a dungeon master to be
honest with you and you know to
to lay the board out for people and to
tell you who has this and what this
would be
it it's really a lot of imagination a
lot of time and a lot of thought and a
lot of caring to it so yeah
to do to do dungeon master i've never
done it that's why i asked you did you
do it
yeah so so so laser corn did you ever
get into the baldur's gate game
uh i uh so the first balder's game i
played was actually this one that
uh i think it's still in early access
but i played the early access a little
bit with the uh
the mind players on the mind player ship
and stuff yeah we got
we got pretty far before the game bugged
out at us
and like we couldn't move any of our
characters but uh well not pretty far
i think we were still in kind of like
the opening acts um but the game bugged
out on us but we were having a lot of
fun with it
i actually have a video up on my channel
of us playing balder's gate yeah
we're having a lot of fun with that i
think i think that game's great uh i
haven't played the earlier ones but
i think there's a lot of potential here
yeah it was the same thing it's that
it's that same sort of
that d thing where it's like okay you
know you could you create the rule set
you can and whatever kind of fits within
it
you people go crazy and i i've always
found that those games
the fact that you could pretty much do
whatever you could do in actual dnd in
those games
is kind of bonkers especially for how
old they are
i really enjoyed uh the divinity games
yeah
same premise yeah yeah
it's a tremendous culture to get i love
that your channel keeps that kind of
stuff alive a lot of diversity and
content
i personally like to pick your poison
games but y'all was forced to pick
between nasty crazy stuff
yeah i was hilarious i like that
dude i got games we haven't even played
yet because of the pandemic i bought
more i got like a godzilla game sitting
there
i got a game called snollygoster which
is a uh
weird i found it on kickstarter it's
like a betrayal game
well like people it's a bunch of people
it's kind of like among us and i bought
it before among us came out
but it's like uh each person on the ship
it's kind of it's
it's space themed and there's like
people that that benefit by other people
dying
um but i got all these games and then
like you know i'm i'm really bummed
about the whole pandemic
yeah you haven't by any chance picked up
the bloodborne
board game have you no i didn't know
they had a board game oh yeah it's like
i think it requires like a small
building to own
it's like the the expansion boxes are
like games unto themselves so
apparently it's some humongous thing
that people don't even know where to put
in their in their house
what type of game is it i have a desk
i get i guess i'm not sure i i don't
know if it's trying to emulate the
actual game experience you know
look at like about to look this up
right now
it's kind of crazy though it's kind of
crazy absolutely yeah that sounds good
man
i would play a bloodborne oh yeah this
looks fun
oh it's got tiles like uh have any of
you guys ever played uh
uh what's it called betrayal at the
house on the hill
no no they have a so they have a
boulder's gate version it's funny that
you mentioned baldur's gate
so there's this game where you build
like a house using different tiles
and then you would venture around the
house until a uh
an omen uh thing happens and then
one player in the house gets transformed
into some kind of monster
and it's a different monster every time
there's like a manual it's like
oh you found the hidden mirror in the
dungeon room
okay turn to page 54. and it's like okay
you just got transformed into a
shape-shifting tentacle monster
and your job is now to kill every other
player in the game it's great
um but that's that's what i immediately
thought of when i saw this so this is
cool so that's what's up man let's solve
this box something so i'll just walk so
we've been looking out for it on the
channel
no doubt absolutely you know other thing
i want to say last thing i want to say
also um
as far as like what i think is really
cool is like the gaming family aspect
like you really do things with the fam
you know he said shout out to the uh to
the laser wife y'all playing portal one
time i saw that was cool yes
you know what i'm saying and yes i want
to shout out one of the funniest things
you did
i felt was all you had a series when
your son was younger
it's like get wrecked son and you were
excited and you
you were taking them through stuff and
it was hilarious so
one spot like having you know bringing
the fam and involving them with the
channel
well uh like uh
during when when we first had tyler he's
he's was around a lot and like
he like would follow me around and i was
doing a lot of uh
shooting a lot of videos from home and
so he would want to be in the videos
he's
in fact one of the first things he ever
said was like daddy we make video
and like you wanted to make videos with
me so i'm like okay
uh but i don't think i you know i play
video games in my videos and like
it's gonna it's gonna be rough for you
because you know you're two
i don't know and he's like ah make video
and so i handed him the controller
i'm like all right and i just turned the
camera on and pretty much started
playing games and then when i obviously
and clearly beat him very badly i was
like well what should we call this video
get rekston
yeah my favorite my favorite uh my
favorite
part in those in those videos was when i
was uh playing injustice with him
and i i was explaining to him oh god you
played it yeah yeah
i love this yeah and then i would i
would use the abilities and i'm like
okay now daddy's punching you into space
okay now daddy's punching you back down
to earth and you're dead
there haven't been many of those videos
on the channel anymore because you can
beat me now so we don't want
to watch that yo i just thought it was
the most funniest concept
yeah it's like child by fire with your
child like you're going to
show him the way get rekt
you need to change it to when he beats
you to get record
wreck dad yeah but yeah
he's deserved now like sounds hilarious
harry is bro
it is hilarious i was rolling man but
salute to him
i love what you do with the family and
then the last question
where i got to ask is of that the name
itself that is is it true the
the urban legend is true that the uh the
name
is from the tap yeah some tattoo
involved
two on my back it'll be unicorn that
shoots lasers
because i have a friend ryan bonaberger
and years ago
god wait i don't even know what year it
was it was again like the 2010
2000 uh no it was earlier that it's like
2009 i think
and he had to he was uh in the marine
corps and he was about to deploy
and he's like i'm like yo what do you
want to do this weekend you know you got
to leave next weekend anything you want
he's like i want to get tattoos
crazy tattoos and i'm like uh
okay i can think of something crazy so
we had a few drinks and
footballed a few ideas and obviously
something like that had to have drinks
involved yeah yeah clearly
i came up with the uh the laser core and
his is actually
better than mine what he came up with
though so a lot of people know about my
tattoo
his tattoo is samuel l jackson from pulp
fiction
riding a t-rex and shooting a gun
it was the best tattoo and it's bigger
than mine
it's like all down here oh my god
yeah and we got those and uh yeah it was
fun
and uh yeah he's in south carolina right
now uh but
uh one day one day and i will get
together and get
second crazier tattoos no no
don't do that king is having flashbacks
right now like no
no no no you know what first of all that
that tattoo artist was wrong because
every time you're a knee braided you're
not supposed to get
no bleed out all over the place
i said we came up with the idea as well
okay let's say we got the test
still went on with it he went on with it
sober
you're like that's a good idea that's a
man of his work that's amazing
the next morning and with a hangover
looked at these
scribbled drawings and then uh and we're
like yeah this still seems like a good
idea
actually when we showed up for our
appointment
they like weren't ready or they're like
oh you guys are here
we're like yeah we emailed you we you
know we sent you the drawings and
they're like
we thought you were joking
we're actually going to come in and get
these dudes like the kids
so even the tattoos
absolutely hilarious stories i gotta ask
the question that we finalized with
people in the realm
i need lord lazy chords top five video
games or
franchises of all time
uh portal number one i love portal
the resident evil franchise uh
phenomenal oh
i uh yeah i i've been playing i i
haven't gotten to play the
the demo for the new one oh man yeah you
gotta put me out there
it's good yeah and then can i combine
warcraft and starcraft
and one okay yeah yeah the craft games
the crap i really like
though yeah let's go uh the real time
strategy not
not wow i mean i like wild but it was i
i didn't play that one
and then uh let's see other franchises
i love um i'd say mario kart is
actually one of my favorite uh
franchises i played all the mario kart
games i uh
i consider oh and i have the uh the new
mario kart
that the switch turns into a camera yeah
yeah the mario kart
track myself you want king r to see okay
so let me tell you something all right
this is
this is something for this when they
announced it
derailing going on right now you know
amazon said
that it's going to be available at this
date and you can pre-order it
i don't know what type of bots they got
over there
but i tried to jump in and i wanted to
get a mario and a luigi set
they were gone literally in seconds
so every time i see somebody with their
unicorn right yeah you're right
ladies and gentlemen you got it and and
you
and boom are the only two people that i
know that i can say i know
that has this thing how is it
it's really fun that's weird that it
sold out because i
uh i got it from a friend although i
think nintendo uh my friend jovenshire
uh has a hookup at nintendo who i think
shipped it right to him
it's really fun um i don't uh
i don't know how how much longevity
there will be to the game
of the game because it's kind of like oh
it's fun and it's novel but
but every time you want to play you got
to set up all the gates and everything
so i don't know how many times we played
it we played it like maybe three or four
times
it's fun but i don't know how long it's
gonna last and if one of the gates
breaks then you gotta fix the gates
but it is enjoyable and the funniest the
funnest part of the game
is just uh the random stuff that happens
like uh like i'll be playing and then my
son will run across
and then you'll see him i'll see him in
the camera go ah and like try and dodge
out of the way
no that's kind of fun and anyone with
pets you'll see like a giant dog on the
screen
that is hilarious it's awesome yeah man
it's definitely definitely picking up
i'm surprised a lot of people
uh flock to it and i i just haven't seen
myself like king but
i have heard the experience is is fun
and one more
you got one more yeah i got one more
gosh for my final it could be a game or
a franchise yep a specific game or a
franchise
important to laser core influential to
you you're personal
i really enjoyed chrono trigger oh
so uh i might have to throw a chrono
trigger in it
fire yeah yeah yeah smiling somewhere
it's slow-motion
huge fan salute last one
and i think you this one should be let's
throw this in real quick because i
i need his opinion on this oh no no
it's not messy it's not messing around
well first off they think i'm about to
say the zelda thing me and king god
i'm about to actually flip this on them
have you played the mass effect oh god
no i don't i don't actually play the
mass effect series but i heard with the
i i might get back into it okay the
remaster right right yes
okay or i might i might actually get
into it for the first time uh
the same guy that sent me the uh the
mario kart thing swears by mass effect
yes
and uh i just uh i feel like a lot of
people are judging you in that game
yes that is accurate that is accurate
remember that yeah that is accurate yeah
you owe yourself to play that trilogy
amazing you know i will and uh
favorite console favorite console of
what time ooh
only have desert island what i uh n64
[Music]
um
he's not my generation but he's one of
the few that have said the n64
because i'm tired of people say pong
[Music]
yeah actually it is
i got to hear it i got it too many happy
memories like goldeneye
mario kart uh they they had bomberman
for the 64.
wrestlers like that multiplayer
wrestling what
ah we did play the wrestling games a
little bit not as much as the other
games okay it was just uh
it was we we had it on rotation it was
like mario kart smash brothers golden
eye
it's like those games which one of those
games are we playing today
and not to mention the goats the
zelda ocarina of time was on that oh yes
uh yeah if you're going single player
yeah
in ocarina of time they had uh perfect
dark was on there yeah
yeah there were a lot of just too many
great games it was a classic uh college
concert and not to me like mario 64
probably single-handedly invented that
whole john really yeah yeah
oh yeah mario 64 was great salute man
tremendous gaming history
love it man we got a couple more topics
before we move on but um yeah man
outstanding i'll say something did we
miss any super chat yeah we got
we got a few first off we have smitty
smith with the two dollar super chat and
lord soph thank you sir
apparently family dealer hates my guts
it's a three-game three-person podcast
salute
i mean last time he was i was like i
don't know
you know what's crazy he knew you was
going to read that
deal i'm inviting myself to rdx salute
get him on the show then we got here we
got kate megan with the two dollars
super chat
what up gamers in iop connect was
amazing
if only there was enough of you that
could have survived
hey i bought that connect 2.0 i was
forced to
so you would have to with that that's
about it
then we got the board game renegade with
the five dollars i have over
400 board games here in the bronx boogie
down oh beautiful
iron lord is welcome to play with me um
that's that sounds good
bro that sounds good
perhaps you should have reworded that
[Laughter]
you can play with me he's gonna he's
gonna have soft on one of those little
rotating things
[Music]
all right last week's poll results in
and the people have spoken to the
question
with the recent reveal of microsoft's q2
earnings
regarding the positive health of the
xbox division what has you
most excited for the future of the
platform
the winner of the poll at 63 percent of
the vote
was more studio acquisitions group
coming in at second at 23 of the vote
was 18 million
plus game pass subscribers in third
place 12
of the vote was xbox overall gaming
revenue and last place with only one
percent of the vote was
they still need to recoup their money
from but that's the deal
[Laughter]
laser cause laughing lord attic your
thoughts they look like they want to do
what you want them to do which is the uh
acquisitions what do you feel addict i
mean obviously it's me
they're right we don't even have to go
any further
like no one else's opinion matters after
that so
let's just go out of the first topic
big old school game that you haven't
played was announcer yeah how is this
your topic
i wanted to hear some more smoke between
you and sam
that's all this is you know the funny
thing i'm gonna i'm gonna hold my
bullets back
oh
obviously we had this remake of these
games that that people
put on a pedestal that you don't seem to
can ever reach like no one else can
reach them
the mass effect games are godly the mass
effect games can't be touched
now i'm about to see about these mass
effect games because they come out
i think may the 14th if i remember
correctly correct and
i'ma play them all apparently they
changed the first one they changed
i don't know if they changed any of the
other ones but i you know i didn't know
laser cord ever played this so uh you
know it's it's good to have someone else
that hasn't played yes very much so this
this iconic franchise that you're scared
to tell people you've never
talked about let's frame it a little bit
so pretty much it's the legendary
edition
you know it's the the trilogy this is
not including mass effect andromeda
um all three games over 40 dlc
remastered in 4k hdr extra uh visual
gameplay updates to mass effect 1
character character creator through all
three games and uh solved correctly from
wrong because fem shep
wasn't in and now well fem shep what
what they're doing is i think the
friendship that they used in mass effect
3
is going to be the standard across all
correct correct so we're doing that and
um yeah it's gonna be four compatible
the playstation five and
series x tons tons of features tons of
enhancements so
let's get it over a little lazy coil who
also has not played like how excited are
you i mean
obviously didn't play the originals
where they came up but is this
gravitating you now to say you know what
let me let me give this thing a shot
yeah i i mean
so once people started talking about it
and stuff i
uh i kind of regret it a little bit not
playing it it just it just didn't look
like it was for me but
you know i've had other friends talking
it up and i'm like ah now i'd have to go
back and play the first one
and the graphics are probably so dated i
won't like it
so the fact that they're releasing a
remaster of it
uh is exciting like i'm like oh okay i
can finally get in on the ground floor
and i feel like i have to now
because i i like i have no excuse not to
play it now right
my excuse before was like i won't be
able to get into it because the graphics
i did now
now it'll be uh up to date and uh i i
think i will play it and and hopefully
it'll live up to
it's it's very hyped now yes it's very
hyped everyone i know that's played it
says says it's very good
so uh so it better be good i guess
i kid you not gonna come back and be
angry at a bunch of people i i
will be in podcasts and they'll be like
and then like the mass effect
topic comes up and i won't even say
nothing i'm just thinking the whole time
please don't ask me anything please
don't ask me because it's like if you
tell people you ain't played massive oh
yeah this is bad yeah
are you a gamer uh are you done like
yeah
good very true very true have to admit
that
so so without spoilers can you can you
kind of sell me on mass effect or it's
from the first one mass effect one yeah
why do i need to play this game someone
someone give me a sales pitch here
can we set it off okay that's offset so
mass effect one
is if you think about it i mean in
general just talking about the whole
the whole truth but make sure you what
they did with the mat what they did with
the mass effect trilogy is they set up
a space opera basically what they they
wanted to make their own star wars right
um star trek yeah yeah actually more
star trek right
where the details of the world are more
important than just like the big
humongous events if you look at the star
wars movie star wars movies about
specifically like the the skywalker
family and and the big events
surrounding them this is about
creating a world um and where you're
basically talking to all the different
species
from around around the milky way in the
universe so it is
it's a story that encompasses everything
about that world from
the human interactions with aliens and
what that means in that world
and and what happens when when they're
threatened on
on on a universe scale on a galactic
level so
it is very much uh what they would call
a space opera
it it it has very very big ambitions
it's not a small thing they're trying to
do here so especially for the time that
it came out
the time it came out was yeah for a game
to have ambitions like that
it was it was really something to to to
kind of open your eyes
it wouldn't it's funny we talk about it
now because you wonder after all this
time like
is are we still looking at it with
rose-colored glasses right right
yeah so it's going to be interesting
framed it well it's like the thing that
also made it amazing was
in the story this is humanity's
like basically the rest of the galactic
civilization is advanced and they have a
say
at the galactic u.n so to speak the
diplomatic there's a u.n of of alien
races and
humanity now finally gets to the table
and the spectre is your story you're a
specter it's almost
should we say like so is there like a
specter for every like species
well that's the thing in the first game
you you
you are you or you become the first
the first human inspector and that has
that has ramifications
right um so yeah yeah yeah so we're
going
to but at the end of the day again it's
it's the rise of humanity to the
forefront you represent that
and the thing that makes it so amazing
is that
you know every choice has impact
and and a lot of these civilizations
have their own
issues and racism between each other
races it's just
a lot of complex issues and then you
have to form a crew yourself
to solve galactic issues so that's kind
of the initial premise of it and it
transforms and i've heard like
like you could have people of the race
that racist is being happening in that
planet on your team
and not only are the people you're
talking to is upset yes
your teammate's like yo i have to pull
you to the side a little bit yeah yeah
and it was the first game not the first
game but you can truly
pursue romantic relationships that was
the best part that was the best part
if you push the issue with certain
characters you could make things pop
you know what i it
made people truly connect with these
characters and
there were life and death decisions also
where
what you did in a game would carry over
if that character died because of
decisions you made or you killed some
character or whatever
that person would be gone and my game
and your game would be completely
different
based on the choices you made everything
had dialogue
impact and it was just it was bioware at
its finest you know it was it was truly
the pinnacle for them and graphically at
the time
it was amazing you know what i'm saying
so it's so much going for it
let's get this super chat because we got
a lot to do i'm sold i'm definitely
going to play
nice nice i mean yeah sure oh we got
bradford the 2000 chat salute lawrence
i'm about to embark on you in a second
though but we got squirrely down with
the five dollars which i cog shamed me
before the show
but not playing the mass effect games
shame on you cog i have
feelings also in a place with masterful
codes on the xbox store
like it's it's it seems like it's a
gaming sin if you ain't playing
no it is it is you're looked at you're
frowned upon in the gaming community
we have brap again with the two dollars
who tapped the elusive man
oh what kind of low-hanging fruit is
that that's martin sheen
of course he's the goat like come on
boys effect two celebrities yeah like
it's like come on that's like denzel
like
automatically the easy w's basic game
game and we got squirrely down with the
two dollars in the chat
hit the like button for the best podcast
on youtube thank you sir
shout out to canada that's the homie
right there always love even though you
give me a hard time
when we play xbox live let's see up
there
squirrelly dead we got some snow today
we can't compete to you you know what
i'm saying
i peeked out the window shot the game he
said y'all all just made me want to play
man
bro we all didn't i didn't
advocate this i don't advocate this
whole let's go
take your legendary edition oh let's go
all kicks ready
let's go king this is typical ea slap
some paint on it and sell you the same
crap that they've been giving you for
years
i mean they could have taken a time out
and did a resident evil remake
they want to do a remaster remasters is
so last gen
oh um and i'm so sick and tired we this
is the
unkept secret you know that everybody
knew about this
everybody knew about this coming for
years and y'all
just eeked it out and eeked
and then said you know finally we're
going to give it to them
when they think that we want it the most
some of us don't want it the most
oh i'm be honest with you don't give me
the same regurgitated crap that you've
been giving me for years the stories
that i already played
and try to play on my nostalgia and
charge me another seventy dollars for it
oh here's the here's the dlc the the 40
packs of dlc and remember
this guy wasn't here and he's available
in the story
don't fix your plot holes that you
messed up oh my god
over again and try to get a different
result no i know how
it begins i know how it uh it's in the
middle and i definitely know how it ends
so you should have fixed it up y'all
should have gave us what was
you know you want my seventy dollars
right and i would love to give you
seventy dollars
not really you know i'm a game passer
let's be real here you are gonna pay won
regardless
exactly i wasn't you know if it was in
game pass i'll try it yeah
um they got so the one we have in this
conversation
it's a lot of people out there capping
at it why didn't catboy fold
it's making people like you and laser
coin feel
i think you could lie to you it's
definitely happening for not playing
this game they should be
shamed
[Laughter]
it was listen they stole a script from
star trek oh
or if you actually watch star trek in
your life then you understood
what mass effects was a parody of mass
effects
because captain kirk was hooking up with
every space person in the world
and look at spectre he's hooking up with
every space person in the world
listen the game is a parody
of a star trek not star wars we're not
even going to touch it with the gospel
right so we're going to give you star
trek the tv version and
you beam down to the planet and they
have the little things going on
and you're trying to figure out how you
can keep your crew happy
and your crew is like um i don't like
his approval rate
are you gonna play the demo when they
put this on no i don't need a devil
unless i really love it
and i don't really like this stuff i
mean i like mass effect but i don't love
it
to be fair uh all three games are in
game pass through va play right now
oh well i'm gonna tell you this i'm not
playing the old crap that i played for
that i paid already see this is the
thing oh so you gotta get it
you're not getting this you you are
putting you're putting a stand you'll
make a hard line stand
against ea how dare they remaster this
beloved trilogy
how dare they do your biggest heart
myself for you
exactly maybe it's for people like us
who have never played
yes well but you know what i can tell
you right now mm-hmm you got ea access
this is the wiggle right
they're not doing nothing special other
than what you're about to do right
literally you can get off this podcast
right now and go play massive x1
you can go play sfx2 and google play
massive x3 and then you can slide into
andromeda
like literally just all of that
and they just they see what they're
doing is they're capitalizing on the
people that don't
know it's an ea access right now that's
on game pass for free rebounds they want
to get
your loading time ea does this
yeah so you're you're saying that the
graphical improvements in the lower
loading times it's not worth it worth to
play the busted old version
let me ask you a question right if
somebody tell you we're going to give
you the same exact thing
right we're going to put a little but
it's not the same thing you keep saying
that but it's not
did you play it yet so what i want you
to
i want you to go and play it now right
and then go play this like go for it is
70 dollars
say i don't think it's there's no so
there's no next gen version
no there's no it's ps4 xbox one
and they're they're playable on next gen
system but they said there will be some
level of it
this will be
listen capcom i love capcom they take
the time out
they remaster
i was just gonna say one thing there is
a legitimate reason why they're still
using
unreal engine three they're not even
used before
use it for
they came they need a w and they need a
quick they need a fairly quick w
right that's for sure they cannot they
cannot
go in and remake these games from the
ground up
because that's not the budget they were
given they were they were given a
a a modest budget to to make make
gold happen right and so but they also
lost
the source code
this is what i just all i hate y'all
saying is well ea needs a win i don't
care
i really don't care what where oh no no
i'm just saying this is this is
this is why it is what it is i don't
disagree with you that
having seen remakes in the vein of
resident evil you're like man why didn't
you do this
but you know people go crazy but it's
more than that too because here's the
thing like
the series is so beloved right that if
they were to alter
anything there's riots let me tell you
how crazy this game is
right let me tell you how crazy rabid
mass effect fans are
when this trilogy concluded right and it
was mass effect 3
right there was an uproar so big
with the ending that people like you i
invested my life this
game was my universe and all you gave me
was said ending with said choices or
whatever this is not enough
they put so much pressure on the studio
they forced the studio to redo
the ending you've never seen that i've
never seen that before
you had to download a 15 gig patch it
was a mia copa
to the rabid fans of mass effect let's
see
we're sorry we want to give you more
context
sorry you didn't like sorry you didn't
like our vision
but now we gonna give you what you want
right
and now that ending is now canon
in the legendary remastered oh who did
they get to write the new did they just
rewrote the ending themselves
themselves they they were shamed by the
fan base
into writing a new ending for a game
they spent a decade
making like that that's i've never
seen yeah that's that says something
about the fan base
i don't know if that says you know
whether or not the the game is
good yeah so just had to carry also i
just i just want to know something here
we go
yes um are you big if if you are huge
into this you don't you're tired of
repackaging content and selling it to us
are you going to be playing destiny
tuesday isn't it
okay shots fired no no
he didn't get anything all right because
when
when when the new season comes out it's
new content
they remastered strikes they're giving
you the fallen saber strike
and they're giving you the strike that
you played in destiny one again
ten dollars the game that you love
they're charging you for that oh wait
it's not free
oh no this is the problem king is going
to play
listen listen i respect you coming for
the crown right now
but i don't need the crown because i
literally no no it's in
oh
it's not that serious we need that cat
emoji to keep
because it's new fans out there there's
a lot of reaching out
that may not know this information that
i'm going to drop some tea
upon you okay right that legendary stuff
is for these rabbit dudes these two
dudes that want to go back i look it's
the
the sky is sparkling that's them all
right don't fall for it
it's in the ea access right now go play
the game
you just want the experience you want to
see those strikes you're a destiny one
go play that no no no
no listen listen i definitely wouldn't
be doing that but what i'm saying is
you have to you don't have to pay for
the glasses and destiny one go play you
can play it you can play there
but i'm doing it i'm just telling you to
save money
now if you don't want to save money
if and if you don't want to save money
and you want to give
this is this is it go test it out
if you don't like it the couple of
seconds that you do play it
then don't buy the legendary edition but
you you didn't save money you just spent
it before the argument that's all
my thing is i've played this stuff right
my level of disappointment with them is
don't give me a 4k
coat and tell me we patched some holes
up and we're going to go
we want to remaster you want to read
this this is what i want yeah right
i'm going to remake excuse me a remake
they're so afraid of their family you
heard these two
tell you they're terrified of their fan
base if they change a hair on specter's
head
and mutinize against them if it makes
them fix it that's true
my thing is you cannot be afraid be bold
mm-hmm but here's the idea i i agree i
agree 100
with you the problem is you're
absolutely right yeah the problem is
because of what has happened with
ea and bioware's last three to four
efforts
right where they've been people have
thrown eggs at the screen yes
people were like what the hell happened
with anthem what the hell happened with
the drum
this is the safe w this is the to get
the fans
back own pocket in line because they're
angry
you know i i don't i have zero in this
in this race right
can we just admit that maybe they're
bringing back this trilogy because they
have another one coming out wait that's
a fact no
that's a fact
like you know people like lasercorns uh
child like
there's so many people that ain't even
touched this game like
like you you got people now my brother's
never played now
the issue with that is the issue was
like i was talking about before
is like the fact that these games at
this point now
are decade or a decade or older right do
is is it going to be super detrimental
to those games to not really
update them in a way a modern gamer's
gonna look and be like wow this is
awesome or
not not looking at him be like wow this
is a nice sheen of uh
on an old ass game i'll agree with you
on that not not taking the time to
properly
you know i don't
like the greedy grab right it's
in game pass it's in e8 but nobody will
play the busted one with the old
busted loading and the wack graph you
know what it actually
it actually
[Music]
until that remake comes out i've seen
the difference i know what it looks like
all right listen i feel you okay i get
it
i can't do this you're talking you're
talking from a perspective of someone
that has played
from a perspective of limited time right
now
and i get that but first off you know i
i would love that they would have put
more time on that
they should have but you know we don't
live in that reality
king is right you know at the end of the
day it's the safe w you know
they they want to just get some goodwill
back
no they've already announced a new mass
effect game so now you got a generation
that hasn't played you got a laser cord
you got an attic
that this is for them it's really f it
is for us for the nostalgia the hardcore
yeah but it's really for them to say hey
this was a great thing
play this and then now yeah you know
later i mean it is equally for both
though because
when they showed the new one right they
made it clear that it was a direct
contain it wasn't andromeda right
it was a direct continuation of the
trilogy that the fans
loved so i mean it's it's it's a play
this is the obvious play to me
right and and you have to and you have
to cash that chip in
as quickly as possible and i think
that's and i always go back to the
argument about
the board room right versus and the
creative rooms
and i think you know at ea more often
than not
the boardroom wins out and they i know
they got a specific budget to make this
game and they said make it happen
right um and the last one i'll say to
king's point and then we'll move on
because i don't know
what we're going wrong with this is that
um you know the thing
let's we got we have to be real about
there are some missing things here right
so one we talked about is pinnacle
station dlc which is not the greatest
dlc let's be real
but it is missing and from my
understanding they lost the source code
or whatever
we also know that this is going to be an
unreal and engine three their reasoning
that they would have to remake the whole
game if it would have been in for
you know i'm with king on that i bet we
work hard for your dog
we break a sweat for your cat i'm with
you on that i wouldn't
seem a little lazy i would have liked i
i i'm pro developers i'm never gonna say
lazy but i would have liked no no no no
no no
i'm talking about the boardroom yeah i
agree i agree i would have liked sure
let's talk about the development right i
know the developers want to give you the
best product facts
not forbid right the developers are like
look
we got this amount of money yeah clearly
lazy what's the wrong word i meant to
say cheap yeah yeah
this is probably how this went the
developers was like look this is how
much we need to do like we got that
unreal injured four
wait wait what what what what's this
use that use that old three that you got
and put it on iphone 7 to record the
video
okay i'll figure it out so at the end of
the day it's still scalable on some
level but at the end of the day
and then the um there's two other points
we gotta make it's that
no multiplayer now the multi-players
from two especially part three
is revered revered it is really good
look i'm giving kick ammunition
don't play it inside game pass where all
the stuff that they've taken out is
there oh
yeah and the last
they're doing this because right now if
they popped out another mass effect
they're going to get the sauves the
kings and the cognitos to buy a new
massive no i'm talking about a brand new
mess
like they don't want just them they want
the laser cords the attics they got
all of us for facts it's the only way to
do it right it's the only
but like i said i don't know if a modern
gamer who hasn't touched these games
before
doesn't look at that and just like oh
that's a nice sheen on an old game
healing game on an old feeling again the
key is when
a laser coin gets it right and he goes
through his like and he
what's his experience like does he feel
that was attic feel that way
you know is it going to resonate with
them that's going to be the key to be
clear
man even like i said taking off the
ropes called the glasses for a minute
like
even back then some of the conversation
stuff felt stilted
when it was happening right you know i
was saying like if you had so many
different choices
especially i got to give a shout out to
femi because friendship was definitely
better acted than regular shepherd
um than male shepherd um so yeah
somebody
some of the conversation stuff feels
stilted in comparison to what you see in
the game like
the last of us two or four the witcher 3
like
comments
imagine me coming back to the iop after
i play this damn trilogy
and i tell and i say i look at cognito
and i look at saul straight in the face
and it's like
what were you guys staying no listen if
you're not feeling
it you're not getting past the first two
hours of the first game
i know you you're gonna drop it like
like like a bad habit
i would advise you if you're not happy
with mass effect one you can clearly
have
your greater experience in mathematics
and then and then you can
we could revisit it i mean mass effect 2
is the more basic experience you might
like that one right
you go you're a stop solve you go that's
our debate
yeah there's a there appears to be a
whole different fight uh
yes just play the original versus wait
for the remake and then there's also
part one versus part two you know
it was funny though part three is still
it's so good though so good everybody
just keeps it out of the comments
nobody bothers with part three anyway
it's fantastic last two points and then
we got to move on
we killed this topic is um all right
there's two little
funny things one collector's edition so
there is a collector's edition with a
life-size
helmet you know what i'm saying it
lights up you got all this little stuff
that's
solving cog or buying i don't know
because i know i'm not going to game is
not included we're just selling you the
helmet
all i have to say is there's a reason
solving cog has a green screen
because if they bought it you'd never
know so you got that and then i thought
this was a
kind of interesting uh switch may be
coming in hot
shout out shout out to the director you
know saying he said he would love
a nintendo switch version of the master
like king's face right now
you know if you're watching man
do it it's unreal three
yes yes so they they could do it i i i
always
like they should have just put the 360
versions on there if that's the case
so pretty much he said look it's not a
priority right now but he would like to
see the possibility of it
obviously mass effect 3 special edition
attic pokemon i didn't know special
edition
mass effect 3 released on the wii u on
the console's launch window i did not
know that
yeah i'm saying so yeah so they they
have done it before so i just thought
that was interesting that the switch
would be in the conversation
and of course we will be having a debate
show versus the evil
song and his cronies am i invited to the
one
after it comes my cronies my cronies
that include
richard hogue bill stillwell and ryan
mccaffrey
i'm i'm i'm assembling my crew yeah we
shall we shall beat you
in his boots a little bit that's that's
that's
that's uh oh yeah she ever forgot look
lord ainsley
you guys yeah but i got some guns i got
some guns
the gun is for you you know what i'm
saying but look
that's what i got we got to move on into
the next topic let's get these super
challenges
please please give us a chance oh we got
squirly dan with the two dollar super
chat
grats on this note we sitting in that
minus 45 to three to four days oh my
goodness
yeah you can keep that i'll take the
snow no thank you i think none of it
there we have the living flame with the
two dollar super chat
i do agree with king sadly demon souls
treatment now i think that's being a
little generous
demon soul's got an entirely you know
new coat of paint
this ain't that this ain't that true
you're going to find out what it is
right then we got pixel bit z with the
two dollars i'm mad at king because he's
right still
okay folded our nostalgia
there we go one away dragons tv with the
five house which
good afternoon lords i'm not buying this
again because
i've beaten all three three times a
piece but they still be dropping in the
year on ea play which equals game pass
that is for sure and it will be there in
the year after they launch that's for
show no doubt
and we got jd gamer with the ten dollars
we'll be chat the problem with it is
that the new mass effect isn't coming
out
for at least two years and you need to
get a new generation
massive it is and to me it needs another
year of development to be the game it
should be that is true though like
you often risk like i honestly the same
thing
gives them another year yeah and that's
the thing they need the w
soon but the new one isn't coming
anytime soon so you can get
pumped but oftentimes you want to you
want to have that sort of
that rush from having played those last
ones immediately translate to a new game
six months later or something like that
that's not going to happen so mm-hmm
yeah so we
are we good no we got one more one more
from jd gamer giving another
uh did you say all that no that this is
a new one from jd um
find out super chat from jd gamer given
another year of dev time
could have moved the unreal four
completely overhauled mass effect one
the way it needs to be while pushing
mass effect one and two to the next
level
yeah and it's but again that's not their
fault i'm sure would
they would have wanted listen they know
the wind that they need
they know the wind that they need and
this is this is treading water because
again for some people it's like oh great
i'm just getting it back you know
i i'm one of those people but there are
a lot of people like kings looking at it
like
really harder than gamepad really so
selling me something i got parked in my
garage
that was good yeah
so this is me man i thought this was a
fun topic um
yeah it looks like uh we we did hear
rumors after the you know the xenomax
thing with microsoft you know that uh
shout out to lois sacha
that uh you know they are still going to
be in the acquisition business right
so a lot of rumors have been flying i
thought this was a fun rumor again rumor
take this with a grain of salt no one is
saying this is definitive these are
rumors so i have to state that
so uh shout out to the white report
[Laughter]
microsoft in talks with sega and
konami to partner with xbox game studios
in japan
for development of exclusive games so
apparently this threat is in spanish
again
take this with a great assault
but this is a fun rumor we gotta talk
about it
wrestling shout out to galapagos
i speak fluent spanish and sometimes you
gotta wonder manny
where are they getting this information
shout out to 41 oh i'd like to
be able to he said i'd like to add a
couple more details for the original
thread okay xbox would have access to
the intellectual properties
and creative heads of sega and konami
sega would keep its pachinko division
which is now we know a separate entity
from his game development
um development division and that we know
is true because we know that they've
recently
sega has separated the business yeah
there's always been a problem with any
corporation trying to acquire them that
the pachinko arcade stuff
and the game we want no pachinko
machines right
we definitely somebody going out right
now and buying an arcade room
especially in a pandemic you know
business is not going no so again it
said and then the final part of it is uh
konami will allegedly
allegedly had conversations with sony
regarding the partnership of a similar
fashion in in um
in the past so again nothing says uh
grain of salt nothing confirmed
now also the source said that the person
that had connections to windows central
shout out to lord jazz he jumped in
front of it
he was like nobody at windows central
has discussed or claimed to have any
information
on this but then the guy kind of replied
back and said i'd like to clarify
the original poster claims his source
does not directly work for windows
central but it's radically heavily
linked
to it as well as other microsoft
divisions so
here is the rumors that's what we hear
right now i want to get this to load
laser corn
as far as potential
microsoft signing eat sega and konami
you know do you one think there's any
truth to it but two and also if
if there is um what do you feel about
would that be good acquisitions for
microsoft do you think
uh yeah i don't know i feel like i feel
like
microsoft might you know light a fire
under konami
and maybe we get uh silent hill
or something because uh they'll give
that ip to that studio they bought with
bethesda
yeah yeah yeah uh but because resident
evil's doing so much and i know the
silent hill fans are uh are not happy so
yeah maybe a good thing but any truth to
it i mean
i i don't you you've got a spanish tweet
that uh these are reputable sources
are you questioning the authenticity of
the white report
yeah i am i'm sorry
it's a fun rumor but as far as any truth
to it
i'm sorry who did you say came out and
said that we're not in talks
shout out to jess gordon the window
central
he just said that that window citroen
did not say this that's already right
because the source the spanish source
said that they had a contact
that was close to windows central and uh
microsoft division so right
so just had to get in front of that but
continue the contact
yeah it seems like if they're coming out
to distance themselves and say whoa hey
hang on
uh then you might not be having a whole
lot of truth to that rumor
i could be wrong though i could be wrong
right crazier things have happened
no doubt no no or it could have been
they jumped the gun and the window
center is like yo
we don't want to be linked to this yeah
sure that's i mean what about saying the
sega excites you in any
capacity for like i said i was a
nintendo kid growing up so i didn't even
play a lot of the
uh you know the sega mainstays like
sonic and stuff so
no not really
[Laughter]
sonic and crazy taxi
for that remastered crazy taxes that
doesn't get you
pumped oh i i know this chat that
they're in mid persona five questions
thanks very much i had the ball i had
the ball the little that's good that was
funny that's funny dude the
lord addict man well what about these
rumors of
what this excites you uh sega
i don't know where the konami thing came
from
like i think that was thrown in there
out of nowhere
like that's why this whole thing is
where did konami come from like i think
there is a lot of truth going on to
what's going on with sega mm-hmm
but konami is there for purchase i have
no
okay i'm sure there's a lot of place
wb's up for personal i mean we did say
microsoft was fine they never mind yeah
but
like look here's my thing microsoft does
not need konami
really i don't i don't care if they make
a new silent hill
what about what about castlevania what
about metal gear
oh yeah it just it just depends on how
much it costs them
like like sega if they let's say they
buy sega
and kunami like first off are they even
linked in any way shape or form
those two specifically segue in konami
no that's the thing that's why
that's why how many studios is konami
hey chad tell me how many studios konami
has i know one of you know
like i just like i don't believe in chad
he's like yo google
you go through that chat how many they
got google i mean
look jean said zero
i just i don't see any value in kunal i
mean i see value in their ips but
you know clearly they're not doing
nothing with them so
i mean you're reading it wrong
what you're reading the white
disrespect you're reading it with black
eyes
that joke was there
let's say there is a possibility that
this happens i mean
i i think sega would help them and you
know konami could help them too because
castlevania to this day still has pool
yeah
i don't think silent hill has any but
you know and that's just because you
know
castlevania still got the you know the
netflix series going on so
you know it's still got some type of ip
that's going on and people still play
that 360 game to this day
can i just say the silent hill fans are
out there though because i've seen the
meat there's memes
you got to be on the right that's
important but there's uh
there's the the guy poking uh konami
with a stick and looking at all the
resident evil remakes and saying come on
do something
there's memes there's silent hill fans
are out there pyramid head
is will always be an iconic yes yeah
yeah he is
like i would if konami was there it
wouldn't bother me but like
i feel like the biggest thing
microsoft's lacking right now is they
can't penetrate other markets pause i
know king i'm going to say pause
they can't get into these other markets
because they don't have these type of
ips right
and that's always been the thorn on
their side is
that is the one genre what there's
multiple genres but that's the one
area that japanese influence that
microsoft doesn't have
right and they need that to get into
some of these markets that they're just
not in
and just to be clear we really want to
hear more on this topic from attic
you can definitely check out the that he
has up he has a very good video
up uh you know uh sega the final piece
um i think you're reading the papers
wrong i think you're reading it wrong
look man right because i can read white
papers just no no
i
[Laughter]
i think that they stepped to these
companies and asked them to
license their ips i think they stepped
to the companies and asked them could
they use their ips to make these games
with the
development houses that they do have so
they do make the games in conjunction
with these companies right so that's
what i think the disconnect is
okay i think there's validity in this i
don't believe that there's acquisitions
right now yeah as far as konami goes
as far as sega goes i believe that there
could be acquisitions in that part
because
after watching addict's video he
enlightened me on a couple of things
now um from my little backdoor stuff
this is not on the level of xenomax
right
right correct so let's let's temper this
back this
this is uh smaller acquisitions to be
honest with you
we're talking about something on a level
of cinematic that's the rumor that's the
real
rumor not even rumor that is i mean
sacha already came out and said they're
still looking at it
he's going with this yeah right so they
want a publisher they want a distributor
and they want uh development uh houses
in that same vein right so when
people try to use these little
development and i'm not saying in sega's
little i know what you're saying vega
used to be a giant before
but they had diminished some over time
when we're talking about pachinko
machines with sega
okay right so they separated from you
don't want to gamble
no not now
[Music]
money is limited and i don't got to be
standing next to that guy who's coughing
a lot
continues sega
is a possibility konami i think they
will license their ips
because i think that ip's is more
important than the konami
right you understand like castlevania
right silence
i agree and you know one thing you could
say that
that might make konami on the table
right is microsoft stated multiple times
they want to get more into the
uh you know the tv show industry the
movie yesterday in castlevania so they
already making a successful sonic
franchise
castlevania is doing really good on that
yeah booty did say that in reference
i'm sure you could make a tv show i'm
sure like laser core said they're out
there somewhere
but sony is more inclined
to have that lane to konami in my
opinion yeah i feel you i think you know
so and i and i think uh silent hill will
come
will launch on a sony platform
my thing is these titles have been
linked
to sony right right castlevania remake
yeah uh uh silent hill metal gear
right metal gear yeah so i don't see how
sony even i mean it's not konami even
uh lines itself with microsoft at any
point i think sega has more
if someone dropped a bag i i don't think
so that's some american studios that
dropped i don't
i think i think right now in japan sony
needs a win
right all right switch is killing this
which is switch
is destroying them and and blocking
their path to success out there
microsoft has taken their path to
success can't stop that
i'm telling you the truth i'm not lying
to you nintendo
is literally shutting them out of their
home territory
they shut themselves up but they're not
having a hand but they all but it seems
like since jim ryan took over the focus
has been america as far as even the
allotment
when you look at it i think that is true
i think i think to
i don't know if king's point really
flies with me just because i just think
because of the shift in how japan plays
games right they're losing that game but
i don't i don't necessarily think
certain franchises will help that on the
playstation front
obviously it's still going to sell but
the problem is i would see like if if
if konami got in bed with with nintendo
and gave your new castlevania on the
switch that's correct that's going to
move the needle yeah
that's going to move the mirror um
getting a new silent hill great but i
think it does
it does go back to i think those games
in this time period
appeal more to western gamers than they
do to japanese games
i just think the way they play is so
different and they haven't seen that
type of game now if you give me a silent
hill game on the switch
no matter how gimped it is i think it's
going to do well just because it's a
silent hill game but i think
at the end of the day those properties
mean more to the west than they do to to
asia now i just it just feels that way i
think we we big those things up more
than they do
right i mean we got to see we got to say
this is an interesting topic um
i definitely want to get one other point
off in reference to um
you know obviously the rumors is still
partnerships that's another thing i want
to clear
as opposed to acquisition all the way
and the only point i throw on it is that
you know
for this listen i'm a sega kid i know
lazy cause i was a sega kid
and for me you know this is what it
would go
okay maddie lost this is the this the
field dominance maximus
you know saying aurelius move for me as
a sega kid i would like to see sega
hold up hold up i gotta call you out a
little bit oh here we go i'll call you
out let's go you you told me
that if they bought sega you would
forfeit oh he's better than peter moore
no no you wouldn't you better repeat it
you're that just one
no i don't know if i'll go there i don't
know if i'll go there i don't know if i
go there i think he's just one of those
just one is separate
at the end of the day at the end of the
day
you know saying peter moore the reason
why i love him so much is because he was
there
during the dreamcast where he was that
guy and then he kind of
spiritually successfully brought a lot
of sega properties over to the ogx box
right
but um and he was the one that says the
famous line that king loves which is
like yo they killed my
sega so that's why i had to ride for
xbox as far as sony and stuff
but for me you know what i'm saying to
revive them
and and now that that because again
people tell me cocky would never happen
because of the sami
thing their pachinko machine the way the
business is run blah blah but they
already made moves to separate lives
now that the moves is made to me again i
don't not saying that all this is true
but they are little tea leaves that yo
this could be possible it's it's like i
said on my video right
there's things that that definitely set
up it's like i said
konami came out of nowhere right right i
don't even know where that came from but
like in terms of sega
you know uh all the awkwardness are in
game passes about now
and and it's not even necessary that
they're in game passes the fact that i
haven't seen one leave
right no family and normally they have
like a six month to a year
i'd assume one would have they keep
adding
it's like all these little tea leaves
again as a sega kid
excite me then yakuza like a dragon
exclusive
if y'all go back to the footage in june
i told you in june oh yeah you said that
lego was on the table i told y'all about
the pachinki machine i told you about
microsoft buying the same
old building that's in downtown tokyo
but
uh all those things line up and then in
in business
we all know that we have to wait for
contracts to run out right right
line up so this could have already been
in the works this stuff could already
been done
and then you know the konami uh renting
ips or purchasing ips and still holding
on to certain stuff
right it could be on the table fast i
mean we don't know
and so i think after this zenimax deal
is done and the tape and we're gonna
learn a lot
as soon as the ink dries we're going to
learn a lot how they're going to move
based on how they actually yeah yeah
that's right so that's the key and
shout out to makai in the chat you know
for me as a sega kid just the
the reimagining of all these classic ips
that they could be single
you know a golden axe like
you know what i'm saying like there's so
many none of that
[Laughter]
here you go throw it over anyway like i
said just the idea of you know
you know licensing that out just aiming
for the cloud that's right
we got we got the streets of rage so why
couldn't we
no i mean it's stuff like that
i know we got your two hour limit you
know i don't know how much time you do
have with us or if you want to rock out
for the last time because i want to be
respectful
of your time sir how are you doing on
time uh yeah yeah i
uh well how long's the the last topic it
will be quicker
let's stick around all right appreciate
you brother appreciate you just
respectful let's get the super chats off
uh we got lord roughness
rumors too yeah you grabbed me by the
collar
oh my gosh sarah hopes room is true
and would love microsoft to bring back
virtual fighter
[Music]
you got to stop that i don't like you
with this aiming for the stars stuff
stop
and we got jd gamer with the 5000 sega
is the cure
with sega we get persona the devs of
hello wars and age of empires
microsoft conquers the console market
they get the win and the peace so
i will be on my field dominance maximus
aurelius
[Laughter]
[Music]
your bed officially at that point what
else we got then we have jd gamer with
the five dollar super chat with the vast
ip rich vault of sega
i say hi to the playstation fans that
have been running from the love of xbox
because we will have their beloved
persona oh my
i would actually really enjoy the
persona being on the xbox platform
that we have jd gamer two dollars for
chat square and capcom are both
zenimax size acquisition they're not
buying capcom aiming for the stock why
don't you just
hey guys ub soft
[Music]
man exclusive just
then we have the uh our rd with the two
two dollar super chat
what about the skype meeting with gabe
newell
i mean yeah i'm sure they have skype
meetings all the time
wherever he is yeah they got bought out
anyway then we got trap line with the
five dollars we chat to king real talk
all week gaming podcasts make me feel
bad about xbox and my series x and every
sunday the king watches it away and keep
the faith
let's be something i'll be on that i'd
say on tick tock thank you my son thank
you thank you
please come and drink of the chalice of
microsoft
who did that that's okay there we have
jean-marc louis with the two dollar
super chat
give me a new altered beast oh lord
let's go
let's go i'm with you man dude we shout
out the liz everybody throw the crest
off for the lizards
that's the homeless brother welcome your
brother that's our destiny brother yeah
we're
we're working on some stuff listen guys
we're working on some stuff to get y'all
uh
more amped up more pumped up system
giveaways and stuff like that when they
become more available and stuff like
that yeah we got some crazy guests there
oh yeah we got fire you know i'm saying
that laser cord actually sets that off
actually he's the avalanche yeah
you ain't gonna i i actually like the
1080 avalanche games that's besides the
point let's go let's go
we all caught up yeah we're here all
right cool so uh look in your
final topic which is quite humorous um
stadia google stadia uh
looks like they let me set it up for you
sir please okay so google stadium is
shutting down
internal game studios so uh yeah man
first reported by kentucky you know
they're gonna be shutting down
internal game development studios and
refocusing on offering their tech to
third-party publishers
this closure kick is laughing this
closure will affect approximately 150
impact on 150 employees um google will
also try to find new roles for those at
the company that were
impacted so yeah it looks like they are
getting out of the first
party studio business why does king have
his xbox star
to the camera um okay the floor is yours
you brought this topic to
the round table what are your thoughts
sir
shout out to the slayer of men the great
bill still will
yes yes yes xcloud was the fast at every
attack i believe
i don't like your board meeting talk i
don't like your corporate kid i don't
like this
i told you why is it
why is he uk corporate kid why did he
what would happen if they did to play
in this arena somebody said something
about this
luminous dude
somebody said he was the true light and
shining armor he
he was he was the way he was the word i
told you the word was dead and he was
not the way
i told you stadio was deal way on rival
and you laughed at me you said the king
they have
money they have buckets of this accent
and i told you i don't like him right
they had
muscles with no conviction
they squat without direction
they hurt they back
the game they said they said literally
they said uh
hey guys whatever you working on shut it
down get it out the door
and uh we're gonna reallocate you guys
to uh google glasses oh that's done too
google glasses is done uh stadium is
done
okay all right don't worry we can send
you over to search engines get to search
engines
and work over there they'll always have
search engines
no one's ever gonna bang anything
[Music]
put them on chromecast put them on
chromecast
but right now they are doing the logical
thing and licensing out their wonderful
tech
now i must say if anybody has got a
chance to try stadia
on any device you realize that the tech
itself behind the product
is fantastic it's it's it's it's
incredible that they get this thing
running in a browser
it was genius in doing so uh just
they didn't support it to the level and
we knew google would not do this
now this doesn't mean this is the death
of stadia this means
the sticks the specs still lives the
text still lives
right who can benefit from this now now
that you're looking at that part
sony can benefit from this sony doesn't
have the infrastructure
let's say that they're smarter they
didn't partner with you know they have
azure
but if you can link that with uh the
stadia tech and
and and i believe that you can you can
be able
to have a viable cloud-based uh
instantaneous type of system
that can run up to 4k you know so i
don't believe stadia is dead i think
this is a reimagining of them
i think they saw exactly where their
pitfalls was
and how much it would cost to get get
them into the game microsoft
has taken almost 20 years to get to the
part where they are now
i don't think stadia had those legs or
had the foresight to even
think that they can achieve that type of
level so they know by licensing tech
they can achieve something they can get
back they get their their
what they spend out on this you know
they can recruit on their course fair
enough lloyd
lasercorn any they surprise you stadia
getting out of the first party business
uh no
i uh i also i didn't believe in stadia
either
i just saw it i didn't think it was
going anywhere but um
it does seem to have some interesting
implications as far as
like uh because i know mmos are kind of
limited by
like servers and stuff so if everything
is happening server side
it uh so like i don't know who could
benefit for this but maybe people
running mmos maybe blizzard i don't know
uh yeah but uh also
what what were what were they saying
before
there's something else interesting with
stadia that i really like oh
well the whole problem with stadia is
it's limited by
internet connection right so if your
internet sucks you know
you're it's going to be buffering all
the time so
i mean maybe it could come back when
everyone has you know
like satellite hyper-fast internet you
know
and it's not a limiting factor for most
people i just feel like too many people
right now don't have the
the yeah to play yeah
especially in the united states like
yeah we're so far behind
the curve when it comes to the internet
yeah fresh
absolute salute solve super chat today
you
um we got jean-marc louie again with the
two dollar super chat
state is going the way of the dodo bird
there we've got gerald back with the ten
dollars for chat the gaming community
should be happy microsoft is on a high
enough level monetarily speaking
to save us from apple google google and
amazon with the purchase of these gaming
companies
shout out to the iop absolutely little
brother thank you
and we got one bad mother with the
dollar handshake
no doubt still spencer's stealth
destroyed the stadium from the inside
where he gave phil harrison that glowing
referral
yo yo that's fine
you see what they doing on twitter they
associate phil harrison with every
failed project
yeah they're bad they i mean they're not
they're not wrong they don't wrong
he was a pianist broke him against
ps3 xbox yeah
[Laughter]
remember when that clown shoe wearing
full on stage [ __ ]
hella is shawn saying about microsoft
sony now fix your face
see your stadium
[Applause]
with the smoke there we go oh no oh no
we got
lord roughness returning with the five
pound super chat yeah
if you're done luna's next and you can
blame this on microsoft 75.5 billion
purchase of xenomax
yes listen what's up bro
i am i am never okay with people losing
their jobs yeah
i'm never okay with that fashion that
aside
that aside uh i am glad it's like a
disclaimer
careful that aside i am pleased that
they are no longer
in the business or market for buying out
gaming studios that i would prefer to
have
go elsewhere i.e the big three
and not not one of those so um i'm glad
they're out of that business but i don't
think
i'm gonna tell you right now it really
felt and i think this is a been a
criticism of bill harrison a lot
that he has he has the peter marley know
as damn ideas ideas but in practice
there is
always something then we'll get onto you
exactly
that in practice there's always
something that does not
work practically yeah um when it came to
stadia obviously it was the pricing
model
that was never going to catch on and i
don't understand why
everyone but them saw that and it it's
just it doesn't make any sense to me
so and beyond that when you look at they
put together all these studios right
and google feels if you look at google's
tracker with anything they put out
if it's not successful quickly and if it
doesn't right and if it doesn't require
and if it requires
an upkeep that is not the level of you
know
google the browser or whatever the it's
it doesn't
it feel like they care about you know
putting the effort in to do that work
and when it comes to gaming gaming isn't
something you trip
into i mean the thing is phil harrison
should have known that right
um jade raymond should have known that
um
this is something you have to put time
money and effort behind to really make
something substantial
right and you were never gonna get
results in a year
that was never going to happen the
problem solved is
a lot of these big companies like google
amazon
they feel like they could just throw
money at something and make it work and
make it work and not
not in gaming man there's too many
hurdles you need
you need time to develop stuff that's
appealing to get an audience that's not
there
you need time to you know scout and look
for stuff that you can't even get
yeah but they're like let's throw three
billion we good yeah we're good we're
good we should be all right we should be
all right and it doesn't work that way
so and at the end of the day um i agree
with king i
mean i i think we said this from the
beginning when we heard about stadium
knowing google that tech will be around
the tech is great and it'll be utilizing
other things
right at the end of the day i think
stadia as a platform it's dave's
unnumbered because
with this announcement of eliminating
the first party studios
they did nothing to rectify the pricing
problem that again puts them at a
disadvantage
against game pass against ps now
like if against all against luna
they still haven't rectified any of that
so they still expecting you as of now to
purchase
games individually on a service um that
once it goes away
you will have no access to it it doesn't
make any sense so
to me it just feels like they're just
letting it ride out first
for however long and then they're just
going to kill it and then what the tech
will remain that's for sure
yeah i'll jump in and finish yourself um
look at the end of the day
you know the thing that their strategy
to me
now you know i'm saying is now we're
going to offer this tech to third-party
companies or whatever so they're getting
out of the first party business right so
to me i still think what they're doing
is not they're not doing microsoft
though microsoft's doing the studio play
like i'm gonna buy the studio
we're gonna have exclusive content we
got this game pass you know now
that's not the play to me what they're
trying to do now is
offer as like they're gonna try to get
ips specifically like for example like
you see like cyberpunk okay hey if we
throw you this bad
time exclusive right right we we want
the timed exclusive on our streaming
platform versus the other
streaming platforms now it remains to be
seen if this new strategy they're gonna
pull an epic game store
right that's literally what it is so now
it's like now here's the thing
there are going to be some companies
right
that that bag is big enough and they're
going to be like yo
okay i'll give you cyberpunk or whatever
the game next big game is
and it's exclusive to your streaming
platform as opposed to an x cloud or a
luna
right and the thing is now since they're
not funding a first party studio
they got a lot more money to throw
around so we are not
rid of them yet because at the end of
the day they still we acting like they
are bad guys again
yeah like the evil forces are not we're
not through
you know what i'm saying because people
will bend the knee to that bag
and i can't come up yet no the and
that's the thing the bag is is enticing
the problem is
the bag would be ten times more enticing
if they just said
hey give us ten dollars a month for our
entire
our entire catalog right yeah yeah
absolutely and that's the mistake
they're making they
because game pass you have the first
part you have all of that in the service
with stadia it's like buy the service
and then buy the
individual games
even if they had something where they
they give you
they give you a license to the game to
download it somewhere like
have some something that they have with
with steam or with with gog or something
where they actually you can actually
download a physical game
facts and the other problem is again now
they jump ship out of this
first party you don't have any unique
exclusive content
you know what i'm saying like you don't
have any compelling now you jumped out
and i'm surprised they jumped out so
fast like they jumped out of that fast
and shout out to homegirl was it jade
raymond she's the one that did like the
assassin's creed like
they invested money into this like they
they when i saw the names that they had
lined up for their first party studios i
was like oh wow
they look like they're taking it serious
like these are some heavy metals in the
industry now
all these big hires for the most part
are laid off and look we're gonna see if
this
this shift to third party works out for
them i i don't know but uh
yeah it was it was very interesting to
see here pull out
that really quickly but that's all i got
oh let's give this a chance to get about
it
okay we have
we have smitty smith no no we got that
one we got the rubber knob
with the five dollar super chat shot
we have breaking news surprise twit uh
surprise twist microsoft buys out
stadium studios
saves them from the bushes that's crazy
that's crazy
uh yeah i think we're caught up all
right no doubt about so let's get this
on i
follow iop pole get up out of here this
will be up on
lords of gaming.net y'all so check it
out it's up now
you can make your vote heard so please
go to lawrencegaming.net
for this the vote the polls are now
going to be there permanently
for the show so with rumors of another
potential microsoft studio or publisher
acquisition
this year which company would you prefer
microsoft to acquire
the choices are a sega japanese
presence and classic ips
b bungie makes sense after the destiny
game pass deal
c konami with metal gear solid
castlevania silent hill
or d i don't care y'all still gotta stop
stadium from snatching y'all ips
such a shout out to everyone that is
going to go up again go to lords of
gaming.net
it's up there right now make your vote
heard check us out man it's lit
and of course shout out to lord
lasercorn of the laser cutter thank you
guys
so much for having me this is a blast oh
brother thank you for hanging out
rocking with us with all our foolishness
for the entire
year yeah i know this is this is fun i
appreciate you brother man tell the fine
people where they can find you and what
you got going on sir
uh youtube.com lasercorn i'm on
instagram uh as the lasercorn twitch
as the lasercorn show and i'm uh
i'm gaming on twitch on my youtube right
now we're running a
a d d series uh so
uh it's remote and so we we're doing
that that's got about three more
episodes left
and yeah that's kind of what i'm doing
right now appreciate you but thanks
again for taking the time busy schedule
really appreciate your story was amazing
love hearing
all the stuff you got planned and all
the stuff i love hearing you guys
arguing
[Laughter]
yeah we was like today to be honest
we try to keep it a little less messy
when we have guys yeah yeah
a little bit for
[Laughter]
absolute pleasure man lord solve where
can the five people find you what you
got going on sir
uh you know me i have to go see about my
cars
and of course bx sovereign on psn and
xbox live
no doubt and of course the co-host
nicole most my man lloyd addict
where can i find people find you what
you got going on you can find me on
twitter lord addict iop
you can find me on youtube gaming
addicts
uh be uh be sure to go in the uh the
chat i put all laser coins
uh information down there so definitely
definitely go down there and follow them
uh you know laser core he he's more of a
comedy person so you know
his the his stage is better
than you know obviously well what's
going on here because
you know he what i like about laser core
is he was one of the very first people
that i saw that just does
comedy like a lot of his stuff is just
it's meant to make you laugh
obviously we do a lot of information
informational stuff here you know
like yeah we're not making people laugh
at all we we do make people laugh you
know mainly
me mainly king but you know
but you know if you want to go to a
place and laugh man have a good time
definitely go over there to laser cord
you know i definitely appreciate it for
coming on because i know definitely you
know it's especially involved everything
going on i want to thank all the people
in the chat
for uh for helping me attack uh
king and that was nice they they were
saying they say i got it back to the
corner
obviously you didn't see it because i
saw it because it wasn't in color so
yeah
if y'all want to have your voices heard
you better do like put the super chat in
color
oh and my bad i forgot to shout out
laser corner because you called me out
of order now
i got stuck on stupid for a second wait
a minute i don't go first
big shout out to lasercorn for coming
through um and shout out to him for
finding that fountain of views because i
looked at him and i was like this guy's
20 years old
it's the orange hair
and of course lord king with the
messiness telling everyone not to buy
mass effect legendary edition
with a slanderer don't waste your money
don't waste your money it's free
i want to give a shout out to ladies and
gentlemen first of all the tattoo joke i
mean the tattoo the story
hilarious crazy it was absolutely crazy
to me
get wrecked son i'm i'm literally going
to watch
just got
yes and um you know you find kindred
spirits wherever you go on your journey
and uh the fact that she was a dungeon
master and i'm like wow
you know it's like little things you
know you get bits and uh
and bites from different people facts
know what what happens in their world
and that was so fantastic to me
um the board game things people need to
keep those things alive
it's more personable and i know you
understand the hardship in trying to
formulate all of that interaction that
you do in the room with the people
and you know to try to get that going so
i'm definitely going to check out the
channel
and he does a lot of animation
i look at that stuff and i'm like nope
not happening well i do some of this
stuff personally
so yeah it's a mix some of the stuff i
do personally and that's the really bad
corny stuff where it's just like
a still figure bouncing up and down but
sometimes i have an actual animator come
in and do like really cool action
nice it bounces back and forth i love it
love it so uh you guys can catch me on
twitter where i'm giving dudes to smoke
for acting out of turn um
[Laughter]
and uh you can see me unbox premium
statues i got a couple of that's uh you
see some boxes over there with mario's
bottom one's king david next week uh
saturday got us some live unboxings i'm
also gonna be meeting up with a couple
of statue collectors
and we're probably gonna go live from
that location yes um
darth castle x yes fridays at 9 00 p.m
just check us out it's a little bit
different and you're gonna have a little
blue
uh king so you know okay curse is wool
oh you lose cake is loose yeah
all over the place but um also i i like
to thank you guys for supporting us
we had 300 plus here uh you know like
and share
um and also looking to our guests
because he sat here for the whole plus
hours facts
and he gave us his wonderful time with
all his energy
so please check out his channel go
subscribe there because i'm definitely
gonna go watch get rekt
you already know soft get the super chat
says more came in real quick we want to
make sure we read those before we head
out yeah no doubt we got smitty smith
two dollar super chat google's pull out
game is strong
oh wow jesus
great show as usual i'm enjoying the ps5
i won from you guys just showing a lot
of a bit of love
no doubt glad that you enjoyed that
brother
who is not jaded
but yeah again thanks for everyone in
the chat again thanks a lot ladies go
for rock it out got a lot of fun stuff
playing man you guys
like adam me and attic no and king
though it's soft though like it's a lot
of fun stuff playing but thanks for
rocking out with us everybody
look enjoy your sunday that's all i got
until next week anybody got anything
else
oh yeah one more thing what's up dealer
this means more yes yes yeah dealer
stop acting like we're a three-man
podcast and salute my man lois off he's
official out here
anyway everybody
[Music]
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
you